welcome everybody to a very special
episode of the h3 podcast we are back in
the studio yeah feels good today's
episode is sponsored by honey expressvpn
and tushy we have a we have as I said a
special episode this is not going to be
a normal podcast we are going to be
responding in full to the notorious
death of h3h3 productions video made by
go kanaru I'll give you some background
basically to fill you in and by the way
we have call ends today from PewDiePie
jontron William Osmond shoenice and
Jimmy Lee are all calling into the show
today it's a blockbuster very excited so
who is go canard oh excuse me go canard
oh I'm gonna give us I'm just gonna try
to set the stage as quickly as I can
because it's a long video it's like an
hour and a half so coconut was just was
at the time a small creator that had
this viral hit the death of h3h3
productions and it's an hour and a half
a ballbuster of me he busts my balls for
hour and a half and he basically says
that I'm a hypocrite or he said his main
thesis is that I can't can't take
criticism and that I'm a hypocrite I
think person you know such and such
people love this video it is beloved by
by many really and it racked up like a
million views I think which is
incredible considering the size of his
channel right
like I think before came out he probably
had 10,000 subs I I don't know I I may
be speaking at turn I know his channel
was small though and it now he has like
you know 140,000 subscribers and this
video made him put him on the spot let's
say so we never responded to this video
people won't wonder why we never
responded to it truthfully the reason is
that or at least directly is that I mean
at the time it came out especially and
even today there's there are a lot of
videos
sizing me on YouTube and I don't at a
certain point you really just can't even
fathom responding to everything you got
I just have to put on your blinders to
an extent so that you can keep living
your life and not just crumble I mean
frankly it's it is difficult to to have
so many videos critiquing you online but
that that's fine
obviously I've muscled through it
obviously there's there's there's a lot
to criticize here so I'm not saying that
you know they shouldn't be made but then
what happened ultimately was a few
months ago the video was removed by
YouTube for a change updated their
policy to include a clause that says
simulate a creator on creator simulated
violence and at the end of his well in
his thumbnail he had him with a gun to
the back of my head and at the end of
his video he has a fairly I would say
graphic assassination seen his video
ends with him assassinating me and
burying me and then spitting on my body
so it's a it's definitely like a very
unsettling creepy assassination scene
and obviously that to me all people
speculate why was removed to me when I
saw that was like oh this is obviously
why it was removed and then there's
further conspiracies that I was the one
responsible for getting the video
removed conspiracies that were put forth
by none other than your beloved keemstar
who said it started with this he says
most vide he said starts with saying
most videos criticizing you when you war
100% messing up years ago have been
removed correct me if I'm wrong but
didn't you have a meeting with Susan
well so he says most I mean it was
literally just one mm-hm Sookie leave it
to keemstar to of course this is what he
does right but this is an Nvidia about
keemstar here he post a picture of us
and Susan
so this is the evidence garbage garbage
so we met with Susan that's true and
apparently also just to reveal
everything if you go to here's here's go
canora's video when he made a video
about his video was removed for
harassment and this is also
circumstantial evidence which is damning
the episode of the podcast where is Gus
Johnson on in that podcast episode when
he clicks the video tab you can see that
my username is in his history as in he
typed my username in there and he knows
how to type it unlike 99% of the people
who are only vaguely aware of me what's
even felt the fact that that somebody
spelled it right as evidence that
funnier is that that podcast was on
April 10th and Susan watch Kiki what
least her like to creator now we're able
to figure out that Susan visited h3 on
April 18th 29th that the evidence is
definitely Mahiwal draw the conclusion
but I will say that that no I'm not
responsible for the video being taken
down
I mean circumstance I mean if you look
at the circumstance it was up for a year
the video had settled why I mean
ultimately why would I have it removed
after it was all settled and obviously
renewed this whole conspiracy about like
censorship I mean doesn't make much
sense to me but the circumstantial
evidence is is clearly damning but I
will say that no I didn't have anything
to do with it and obviously somebody
typed it in on this laptop I agree with
that I don't I don't know who it was I
mean a lot of people use this laptop so
it may have been me I don't know but but
I did but I didn't tell her to remove
your video I could tell you that for
sure I remember the content of our
conversation the thing is if you go to
the blog post he kind of makes it sound
like we just talked about crater on
crater harassment but she met with a ton
of creators and she talked about here's
this blog post living up to our
responsibility
support creator and artist success and
improving communication is dangerous I
remember the whole content of our
conversation was about me bitching at
her that they need to do more to help
edgy channels as they call them because
all of my friends with normal channels
their CPM rebounded and my rep at
YouTube is always like oh everyone CPMs
are fine and they're making more money
than they ever did and I'm like well
well I know that my CPM is worse than
it's ever been because they they added
these are families that add revenue I
don't know if everyone sad rate terms
like price per thousand views or
whatever how much you get paid and
because they added all these new like
systems to protect brands from going on
edgy channels and I'm and I'm like my
argument to her is like why is it that
if you go on Comedy Central or MTV or
add that all back in the day but well
these are like South Park like these are
the shows that advertisers will want to
be on so why is it that you guys can't
figure out how to sell ads to content
like mine and a lot of other people's
that make content similar to mine right
why is it you can't figure that out that
seems to me like a huge missed
opportunity for both of us so that that
was what I [ __ ] to her about the entire
time and actually well at any rate so
that that's what I was talking to her
about so anyway people seem to think
that I have the really Susan you guys
have to understand is one of the richest
most powerful women on in the planet on
the planet I love that you guys think I
have her under my thumb but
unfortunately that's the only time I've
spoken to her and we did not discuss
coca Naro although I will give it up
that that the evidence is strong there
circumstantially yada yada yada
but but ultimately you guys will see
when I get to that end scene it's it is
pretty graphic and gokhan are we even
says in one of his videos that he thinks
that seeing crossed the line and if he
really wanted the video back up I just
don't understand why he wouldn't just
cut that part out right
like people reload the video
and then they're like uh censorship is
being taken down but if you look on
YouTube now any of anyone who cut out
that and seen the video is still up and
that and you know that's that's
YouTube's rule okay so this video has
gained this mythical reputation of
between this conspiracies with me and
Susan and the censorship and like how it
just went viral that now now it's just
become this huge thing and like people
are reposting it like as some kind of
anti censorship thing and that's fine
but I want I figure out well [ __ ]
let's just watch the damn thing because
it's the video you don't want people
yeah I think that's what people are
marketing it as that's what keemstar
like he posted on his channel is the
video he thought you to see well
actually that's not true to the point
where I'll let's all watch it together
so with that being said let's just jump
right into it in the words of the great
Philip DeFranco so here we go now now in
the in the sake of brevity there's like
a whole intro sketch that's three
minutes long that I don't have much to
comment on so I'm just gonna skip that
and go straight to the criticism but he
basically is plotting to kill me
essentially in the intro sketch he's he
spits blood on my poster he's obsessed
with me he's doing karate it's kind of
like a taxicab ask just weird obsession
and he wants to kill me that that's the
character that's a driver taxi driver
yeah thank you Dad so anyway this is
chapter one first blood leafy and pyro
this incline has done a lot for the
YouTube community and his main channel
videos are pretty funny thank you so why
am I making this video because he's a
hypocrite because he can't take
criticism
[Music]
this whole story started with Ethan
taking one big risk did his room by the
way I know it's not relevant but his
room is so messy well our old video
thank you but if you're making your big
Magnus opus you think it was like clean
up your room a little bit most of you
guys probably know leafy is here popular
youtuber has been blowing up big time
I'm actually friends with these guys so
it's awkward it's uncomfortable but for
some reason we as a community have been
giving these guys a pass and I mean if
you look at leafy's Channel all he does
is make fun of kids and like vulnerable
people no there's no sport and making
fun of these people they're just it's
just sad it's it's stupid
honestly that we vogue on this one
giving these these channels of Pat's who
are cancerous I'm serious
so Ethan calls out leafy for bullying
kids and bullying disadvantaged people
in his videos and you know I'm not upset
about that that's not the issue here
the issue is this and likely in that Sun
oh the conspiracy depends friends you
know you're friends with this guy
me and leafy are friends alright so
you're friends with him so how exactly
did did you get to this point like
actually I'll let you play it play along
at home what do you think did Ethan a
discuss the video with leafy prior to
uploading it be upload it with no
warning whatsoever or be because the ant
the answer is the answer is B all right
so right off the bat that establishes
that Ethan's goal and this was not to
stop the leafy from bullying kids it was
to stir the pot to get oh well heirloom
drama going to come out as the hero well
I don't I don't agree necessary that
conclusion
I don't see why me telling him ahead of
time has anything to do with me just
wanting to stir the pot the truth about
that situation though is that I think in
that video I did make a mistake by
referring to leaf he has my friend
because we were acquaintances which is
something that I kind of I messed up
because leafy played up that angle in
his video about we were friends any
better but that that wasn't really the
it was it's just this kind of like
creator following another creator if
talking in DMS yeah it's not really
friends you know but but but but okay
but but to draw the conclusion that I
don't didn't care about what I was
talking about is uh
I don't understand how he can draw the
conclusion from the fact that I didn't
tell leafy that I was making a video
fine with that you can do that I love
stirring the pot however you made one
crucial little error I really just want
to see his channel die out [ __ ] hate
him and his channel don't give power or
platform to defend himself merely fear
friends you know oh [ __ ] we're friends I
mean that's terrific man I mean I should
have known so that you literally were
sucking my dick about my channel about a
month ago happy for you blowing up
you got a unique style and personality
man by the way a month a month ago and
leafy time I don't know what was the
temporal but that was when I first
discovered him and then he started
making all these really like going down
this path of like [ __ ] on kids and
stuff he was making videos daily so it
was actually a long a long time I think
it was more than a month he worked hard
to get where you are and you deserve it
it just pisses me off to see pyro
writing yours to undeserved success this
was the first time that we got a good
look at the true jealous manipulative
side of h3h3 or Ethan he straight up
calling pyrocynical pirates cynical a
psychopath cancer no goofs no gaffes
this is his honest unfiltered opinion
between two peers in the same platform
but recently I've actually had a lot of
private messages sent to me of hates
tree hate street giving me a lot of [ __ ]
saying how my channel is cancer saying
how I'm completely unoriginal and I'm a
total sociopath
now pyro being a level-headed and
self-aware guy came out on this position
on top do you know why because he knows
how to handle criticism he knows how to
deflect it he's smart no even though
Ethan said all this [ __ ] about me I'm
pretty sure he'd kill me if he saw me in
real life I'm gonna respect his privacy
and not show any of these messages
except that was genuine I always to
cross with the notion that I would kill
him in real life it's just but okay I'm
gonna let him finish this point and then
what happens when the peasant calls out
the Saints himself does h3h3 productions
code him and say you are cancer
[ __ ] I set it here and I'm gonna
say it now your cancer no dude
guess what he does he [ __ ] lie is he
tweets out saying why you straight lying
dog okay so here it was also revealed
that Ethan directly lied in a tweet to
pyro
when pyro had some suspicions that Ethan
was conspiring against him with other
youtubers
Ethan immediately said no dude why you
spreading lies so okay let's unpack that
so when I tweeted at pyro I'm gonna give
context to this whole thing so first of
all let me just address I had this come
up we're getting we have whatsapp open
was that down right so we we were having
me and leafy were having a conversation
about pyro privately and first of all it
was super embarrassing that I I look
back on the conversation with great
shame it was very embarrassing and it
was totally out of line that I was
speaking with pirate about pyro like
that I totally owned that but now let's
go look at the context because I think
it's important first of all when you
watch this video to see how he opens it
he says he tempers the audience
expectation by starting it by saying the
following video was completed after
hundreds of hours of research recording
and editing so so I'm presuming that he
did all the research which is strange
because if you just go to Google and
literally type h3h3 leafyishere dm's
here I'll do it right here watch because
I was I was just kind of I was looking
good leaf he dumped our whole DM
conversation in his video so I was like
oh I I know they're still out there so I
go leafy is here DMS h3h3 and the first
top result look right here let's let's
click this
so this is the big write-up I made about
it because I didn't want to make a video
response but let's see basically leafy's
sent him like leafy made it look like I
was just railing on pyro but this is
[ __ ] the leafies was sending me Pyro's a
[ __ ] psychopath yeah he's a [ __ ]
rat dude god I [ __ ] hate this guy
he's a scum [ __ ] this guy likewise man I
hopefully he just falls in a ditch yep
he's cancer literally told me not to
associate with this I should have
listened he's [ __ ] crazy so I mean
like that that was just the Bible of
conversation which is super cringy I
agree there's this weird thing like that
I was trying to get people to make a
video about pyro which is so out of
character and insane that's something
that I would never do if you go look at
our DMS conversations that by the way
pyrrol red and everybody red right it's
he leaf he says like ten youtubers has
brought up the titles think to me yeah
don't worry it was like 10 other
youtubers do you want me to bring up the
over he's making a video and talking
with other youtubers about making videos
about him I said no don't bring it up
it's fine he says he's been ripping off
montage parody people forever he ripped
them off too so he's talking with people
about about making videos to pyro I said
this is between us right yeah don't
worry I'm not saying anything I never
said anything earlier either it was just
a few youtubers saw the title thing I
said thanks man
no problem we'll all in it's together
[ __ ] this guy I said you know what I'm
not interested in blasting him publicly
alright you know what just leave it it's
fine I'm sorry and he says you don't
have to explain yourself he's says if I
bring it up he'll stop and he can't do
anything about it I said if I have an
issue I should confront him about it and
not have you do it on my behalf and
that's where I left it I said if I've
got a problem
I'll just tell him I don't want to blast
him publicly which is funny because in
the video he cites leaf he says the
exact opposite that I would went behind
his back but again he's citing leafy
right like leafies original video and if
he did all this research
really he would have read my post but
like just take it from somebody who
actually who actually watched the videos
right look at this this also came up
when I just type h3h3 leafy [ __ ] dm's
look at take it from this guy it was
wrong about h3h3 the thing is is like
when h3 and leafy we're talking about
pyro they were talking about destroying
pyro right but leafy is the one that
brought it up
this was leafies idea to destroy
pyrocynical so the two of them start
talking [ __ ] about how much they don't
like him in the DMS and somewhere along
the line dat [ __ ] h3 h3 drops the the
best meme line ever do not give him a
platform to defend himself and leafies
all gun ho let's destroy pyro but then
as the conversation goes on h3 h3
realizes that you know this is kind of
on a line and Ethan literally says in
the [ __ ] DMS yeah let's not do this
this is this is not cool that's not a
good idea let's just drop it and leafy
still wants to attack pyro
now when leafy exposes h3 h3 for
plotting on pyro leaf he doesn't show
any of the goddamn DMS that he started
it that he still want to do it or the
fact that [ __ ] Ethan no longer wanted
to attack pyro it was just two guys
talking [ __ ] and a private DM and leafy
manipulated everyone by taking that one
line out and showing everyone don't give
pyro a platform to defend himself all
this [ __ ] information comes out in
the new beta podcast that's about to
drop me clown and Tommy all seen the
full DMS and I'm telling you right now
Ethan h3h3 is [ __ ] innocent right yes
he was talking [ __ ] in a moment but he
decided not to go after pyro when this
was leafies idea and leafy still wanted
to go after pyro leaf he lied and
manipulated everyone well then he has so
many who are different
I mean he seems like a really stand-up
guy who better to speak up for me than
keemstar
he's actually got the right take like
what happened but I think this is this
just show goes to show like when when
Kim star doesn't when he's on your not
on your and his dear analyst but no he
says I read the DMS and to quote him
h3h3 is innocent but I have to question
go canarios research because he says he
did hundreds of our research and then I
have to assume he also watched the
baited podcast where we talk about this
specific issue at great length and
explain all this so the fact that he's
actually bringing up this old leafy
video is without any context or
amendment kind of either either his
research is not as good as he says or
it's like a really bad faith argument
that's my take as you've seen have you
seen keemstar explained for himself so
like yeah I mean he sets up the video
with this what this whole narrative that
I'm trying to get people to make a video
on pyrrol which is just it's been proven
wrong and so and that was what you meant
right when you Twitter that pyro ways
yes of course
he said in this video that I was trying
to make videos get people to make videos
on him I'm like what so that's why I
said why are you lying about me
literally because I was like dude that's
crazy like that's just crazy like what
are you [ __ ] okay so here it was also
revealed that Ethan directly lied in a
tweet to piracy based on what did I lie
I don't understand what he's what
how could he conclude that when pyro had
some suspicions that Ethan was
conspiring against him with other
youtubers Ethan immediately said no dude
why he's for you because it was a lion
you can you could have looked it up
easily or I'm assuming you did see it
and on your research but you decided to
leave it out so that's an interesting
way to start the video that's all I'm
saying ironic
[Music]
hypocrisy counter number one baby I'd
like someone to pick on your own size
seriously did this part he shows I'm
saying find someone to pick on your own
size and I have 1 million subs and pyro
has 700,000 and apparently I'm punching
down because of that by the that's
generally considered the same size yeah
I mean a million in 700 but also I'm bi
also I'm having a private conversation
and I said in that conversation that I
don't want to blast him publicly so it's
a strip that's quite a stretch picking
on kids
so his pucker his hypocrisy counters at
2 but I think I couldn't wash both of
those away I wouldn't exactly so he was
recruiting a army of small chant I mean
Timmy braaap stand people that again
he's using leafy's old arguments which
is pretty weird but Timmy brafton was
the one time we made fun of a kid but I
feel like if you watch that video you'll
see that it's not that bad
I don't know I mean also there's an
argument of us evolving over time that's
something that we currently don't do or
at the time even stop doing you know at
the time we made that video our channel
was small and when your channel small
you have this attitude of like nobody's
gonna see this yeah and very much I bear
that in mind with him too because I
actually want to give gokhan ro a lot of
benefit of the doubt here cuz I think
he's actually a talented content creator
and I don't want to [ __ ] on him
personally because when he made this
video his show is very small and he said
himself he didn't expect anyone to watch
it so you know a lot of stuff I'm
pointing out like now that it's gone
like viral and everybody thinks it's
like such an important video it's
important for me to talk about these
issues and set the record straight but
on a personal level I understand why why
it you know he would try to manipulate
things because he he goes look I just
trying to make a good video people are
gonna watch it when you have a
million-plus subs then you understand
you have more responsibility to you know
say things straight or to have more care
but obviously now I wouldn't go make a
funny video and Jimmy Braff's did that'd
be insane
Timmy Timmy sorry Timmy beat Thomas to
basically try and conspire against
pyrocynical you know like Wow
instead of doing a video yourself you
decided cronies and get them to do the
dirty literally gonna happen to try and
topple this guy well I mean that's your
blue I mean that I mean the opposite
happened I said this is stupid I don't
want to do it but okay well let's we can
move past this but what is this a known
as h3h3 productions do after he's been
caught lying [ __ ] dude look at this
[ __ ] damage control he professed his
love to fire cynical he said if he was a
skull you know what's crazy about this
he's he's referencing my post here which
means he read it so he mediums and you
know that's crazy because he's literally
saying I read the post but I'm not
acknowledging the fact that what I'm
saying is factually inaccurate which
proves that this is actually a bad faith
argument basically the half-assed
apology that we got you know in
retrospect I can't even imagine how
gleeful you must have been when that
content cop was really just everybody
was wait a minute that's why I dubs
create some of the points for that video
so again you're gonna notice throughout
this video that it's like 90%
speculation which is wrong too by the
way what he does is his device is that
he speculates but what he says is he
speaks it like it's true fact
and he always takes like the most
negative possible way so he says Ethan
you could help items make his video
that's not true we literally shot he
literally said hey you want to do this
shot with me looking at the poster just
like a little Easter Egg and that was
the extent I had nothing to do with
idubbbz content cop
but he's just speculating he doesn't
know well look at that he thin you ended
up getting what you wanted
you got to bash somebody through the
mouth of another
I mean that whole point just wrong wrong
yeah
[Music]
friend in need not ready you were
actually at 30 minutes guys do not go
away we are gonna take a quick break for
sponsors and we will be back in railroad
through this babe
you poop you wash you dry it's a
three-step process and touchy is in the
business of blasting that ass with water
everyone has an ass and everyone
deserves the gift of tishy listen you
know that I've been converted from the
wiping to the bidet is a revolution
putting your hand in your butt it's
disgusting and it doesn't even move all
the [ __ ] out all over the place you know
you're just smearing [ __ ] around your
[ __ ] it's not even dry you know paper
is not good for the environment so now
it's time to get a sleek bidet
attachment that clips onto your existing
toilet and sprays your butt completely
clean with fresh water
it's called tushy and it's the best
thing you can do for your butt till she
sprays directly to your ass
I love this coffee it's awesome that's
what it does though sprays it directly
to your ass and removes the poop
completely so you aren't sitting on
bacteria that leads to nasty things like
hemorrhoids yeast infections UTIs and
itchy ass holes and skid marks good
point
Toshi the days are common in the rest of
the world so why is America just still
schmira ng [ __ ] all over their [ __ ]
a bidet saves you money on toilet paper
like seriously during the cove in 1912
the paper shortage but day is the way of
the future it won't clog your toilet and
tushie sprays your ass with fresh water
it's not toilet water till she connects
to the water supply behind your toilet
to spray your dirty parts with clean
fresh water it's the same water you
brush your teeth with wet wipes are
worse than toilet paper you know that we
learned that here it's terrible for the
environment and it caused anal fissures
you don't want your anus fissuring hell
no oh and here's the best part it only
costs $79 Wow
Toshi helps you get everything out
it's like a sexy tooth or cloud that
helps you poop and it's wait what's the
Toshi ottoman yeah that's a separate
product a separate it's a helps you get
everything out and it's a sexy tooth or
cloud that helps you poop and it's only
$69 nice I'm curious about the Ottoman
yeah the Ottoman if you go to their
website tushy ottoman
oh my god I have to buy this I don't
want that that's it bro that's touchy
ottoman my dudes that's what's up you
got to put your feet up so you can [ __ ]
good that's crazy
so that's 69 bucks if you want the whole
[ __ ] package go - hello - she calm /
h3h3 get 10% off your order
that is a great offer they start
squirting water up your ass - I'm
telling you and that's $79 get in the
door come on it's touchy all right so
you all know how expressvpn protects
your privacy and security online but
here's something you might not know you
can also use Express VPN to unlock
movies in shows that are only available
in other countries now that so many of
us are stuck at home it's only a matter
of time until you run out of stuff to
watch on Netflix so this whole week I've
been using expressvpn to binge Doctor
Who on UK Netflix boy I love me some
Doctor Who and it's hard to find cuz the
BBC got their [ __ ] locked and down but
with expressvpn you could just bypass
all that I'll watch it on freaking
Netflix the UK of all places it's so
simple to do I just fire up the
expressvpn app change my location to the
UK refresh Netflix and Bob is your uncle
as they say in England see expressly
beyond hide your IP address and let you
control where you want sites to think
you're located you could choose from
almost 100 different countries and so
just think about all the Netflix
libraries you can go through mmm love
anime
use Express VPN Japan oh but it's not
just Netflix expressvpn works with any
streaming service hulu BBC iPlayer
YouTube you name it there are hundreds
of VPNs out there but the reason I use
Express VPN to watch shows is because
it's ridiculously fast there's never any
buffering or lag and you can stream an
HD no problem babe a expressvpn is also
compatible with all your devices phones
Media consoles Smart TVs and more so you
can watch what you want on a personal
device or the big screen wherever you
are let's go if you visit my special
link right now
expressvpn comm / h3 you can get an
extra three months of expressvpn for
free support our show now is a better
time than ever to support us watch what
you want and protect yourself with
expressvpn Express VPN comm / h3
honey is the [ __ ] we all shop online a
lot now more than ever but did you know
you can make online shopping even better
with honey honey is a free online
shopping tool that saves you money
online honey
automatically finds the best promo codes
and applies them to your cart which
makes online shopping finally feel as
easy as it's supposed to be now you
don't have to neurotically check the
whole internet for the best coupon code
and know if you're getting the best
price honey does it for you
automatically take for example this
either was shopping for jewelry what was
the website again this is how it works
you go to checkout you have no
expectation of making money and then as
you're checking out honey's like hold on
I got you boo or BAE
I got you BAE and then it's like oh look
I just saved you 31 bucks
literally automatically it finds this
code boom save 30 bucks is ridiculous
whether you're at Target Papa John's
Sephora Macy's su Walmart etc when you
check out there's this little drop box
down all you have to do is click apply
coupons wait a few seconds for it to
scan and voila that's it it's really
that simple
what did you buy that honey saw we do
dododo it up papa honey has found it's
over 18 million members over 2 billion
dollars in savings
did you know honey supports over 30,000
stores online and they're adding more
every day users love honey that's why it
has over a hundred thousand five-star
reviews on Google Chrome store it is
literally that easy if you don't believe
me all you got to do is install it for
free it's owned by PayPal so you know
they're the real deal it's just just two
clicks it's a plugin so go get it for
free at join honeycomb slash h3 that's
you join honeycomb / H slave if you
don't believe me just try it see how
easy it is it's free it's God blessed
it's beautiful it's honey
all right moving on a friend in need
let's watch
okay so Ethan let's be clear you weren't
really friends with leafy you rekt
talked in the d-ends you bashed pyro
together but really you weren't friends
yeah so already we know your definition
of friendship is a little bit loose
jontron however is undeniably a good
friend of yours I won't even deny it
myself
jeonse the reason we came out to New
York it's a great producing when we were
we were we were pieces of [ __ ] we had no
prospects no money no job Johnson I'm
gonna take carry you kid I'm gonna give
your home and give you guys work I'm
gonna give you guys purpose he brought
us out here
so when jontron gets in trouble for the
debate with destiny where he said some
controversial things you kept quiet
about it I mean you make it clear that
you disagree with what he said but you
know you stay silent pretty well you
know you don't you don't discuss it
publicly which is okay that's another
thing about fine response you know he
loses it nothing ever happened with the
bail I don't think so interesting why
the belt ports John and that's a fine
reaction to have it's smart okay just
keep that situation the back your head
for a bit now around the same time
PewDiePie gets in trouble for some
[ __ ] complete you know horseshit and
Ethan you vehemently support PewDiePie
you know and you should because you're
his friend and because he's right but
also because you're his friend you know
you should always support your friends
no I mean that's that that's just that
first of all that's like I mean I
disagree with that premise the thing is
that I defended PewDiePie because I
thought first of all I came from a place
of being able to speak on it because I
was I'm a Jewish person but but I felt
like it was totally [ __ ] that people
were calling him anti-semitic I mean it
was just he really isn't and so to say
that because I didn't defend John also
to me the argue of like you should
always support a friend that's more like
what you do behind the scenes like yes
you should always support a friend but
that's more of other stuff that you
wouldn't see anyway whatever we do to
support our friends the thing is like
and I say I disagree with John's takes
so obviously why would I come out and
support him but but but I didn't I was I
was very communicate I talked you guys I
talked with John all the time I was
talking with him throughout that whole
controversy and you know trying to
support him the best I could but okay
let's see
you should always support your friends
when they have more subs than you in
public opinion is on your side it's a
joke he's not late John has more heart
John had more what is that John is a big
channel I don't know what he's talking
about
right he says I only supported PewDiePie
because public opinion was on my side
and he has more subs but wouldn't that
caught wouldn't that go against his
theory that but that he's leading to was
that I criticized PewDiePie when he said
that all right the N word so I was going
against public opinion in that there's a
big difference guys context matters as a
Jewish person I'm not offended
flash-forward well cutie pies in hot
water man he says the N word yeah he
dropped he dropped the N bomb but the
situations are completely different well
I don't understand why why this is proof
of anything he dropped it pretty hard
was more of just like a Hiroshima it's
pretty much worst-case scenario you know
when they drop nuclear bombs and and the
people out on the street have like
shadows left over and printed on the
sidewalk it's like that I don't think
Felix is a racist person but goddamn he
really kind of just was really
comfortable using that word that really
just kind of I loved oh good the guy's
turn and bomb yeah so okay on this point
I'll totally own that this was a really
bad take and a huge mistake
you know in my mind I was rational I
obviously I knew that I had said the
n-word when I doves was on the show the
context of that of course was that we
are having a idubbbz famously would say
the inner effort and I was like how do
you get away with saying that you know
and then I started saying it and it
turned into what I thought was a
where I was saying it but in my mind I
was like well we're having a
conversation about this word and I
wasn't using it as a pejorative insult
right
that being said obviously that's a
nuanced convert a nuanced point and and
and there's plenty of people who think
well it doesn't matter how you use it
anyway
and honestly even ourselves have changed
yes since I don't think today you would
know know I cringe so hard when I see
that yeah me saying that and thinking of
thinking that it's okay
no I wouldn't say that now and I find it
horribly embarrassing and I was
definitely hypocritical in this moment
there's no question about it
like I've totally owned that you know
like straight up I'm gonna skip to the
why he's all about the dangerous double
down chapter three baby
Ethan why'd you do this because it's a
hot topic and you want the public to
know that your views are rock-solid do
you know why I know this it's because
you're a disingenuous opportunistic
person who is not afraid to ride the
wave of hate so long as it stays away
from you but it didn't you go do you
think we should throw it now damn to PA
PI I was thinking at the conclusion of
him talking about all this but whenever
it feels this part is also about him
isn't right that's why I got called out
for this one
big time because people saw you got a
little too cocky you got a little too
confident h3h3 uploaded this podcaster
yes true I'll own that I think I was too
caught cocky and confident and I thought
I'm gonna do a whole episode about the N
word and is it okay to say the N word
and I brought eat that [ __ ] on and we
had a whole it but yeah I mean I totally
agree that was I was way too cocky and
that whole episode was outrageous you
know it has over 28,000 dislikes on his
most recent podcast almost more dislikes
than likes on this thing they think that
Ethan h3h3 is being a hypocrite because
on his podcast he said the N word - so
I'm sure h3 she will like that he's a
great dude and I know he'll come back
from this obviously I think you're just
gonna have to explain it more we can I
will say here let me I'm gonna let play
friends and you can still criticize me
yeah but you have keemstar and scares
who are like eh threes a hypocrite oh
because he said on his podcast you know
sores like get [ __ ] real I'm getting
more [ __ ] than my pie hey I'm just gonna
say this is the most embarrassing thing
I've ever done this was awful like it
was awful I hate that time - it was such
a bad time in general I went to Israel
because my dad was sick yeah and then
you were here doing this episode and you
got all drunk and it was just all around
bad it was drunk on a live stream
you can't pet it yeah but I don't know
what I think it was just a weird time I
just I got so defensive about it and I
was fully in the wrong I mean there's no
question about it and it's just awful it
just it's just so awful I especially
feel bad because I called out scarce and
honestly scarce it's such a sweet guy
such a nice dude and I really feel bad
that I spoke ill of scarce because he's
just he's just a sweetheart and really
he didn't deserve it I'm fully with you
I'm News but I don't actually look at
them to skip this part I'm gonna skip it
just because I totally agree oh and we
have an hour and a half to watch
according to the internet the news and
this is the news people are calling you
right he's right channel is making fun
of people and curtiss-wright legitimize
anybody's right the only thing I really
want to apologize for drunken man and
you know about the context hypocritical
thing I don't think I'm a hypocrite most
of the people who were upset about it
probably didn't watch the whole episode
because the the harshest criticism I
landed against PewDiePie was that I was
disappointed hey future Chris here real
quick I need to clarify and make very
clear the point I'm trying to make here
Ethan the issue here was not that what
you were saying was wrong it's that you
were the wrong person to be saying he's
right that's a good point that he was
live-streaming when he said it and that
he sounded like he was very comfortable
using it and then there's footage may
arrive you totally right we're
comfortable saying it on a live stream
multiple times on like are you you had
to have forgotten that that clip exists
I didn't forget but I thought it was
complete idiot I didn't forget but I
thought in my mind's eye justified that
the context was different enough but
obviously that was not true Oh like just
think about it this way why do you think
idubbbz
did not say anything because he's smart
he knows he's the wrong person he's
right about that two items did not say
it and I was rambling on like an idiot
saying it all this time beautify
exactly oh but I remember because even
on that podcast items like whoo you're
saying a lot you saying anything about
the situation he needs to stay silent
whereas you just wanted to use it as a
fresh scoop for the podcast and it
worked
that's real quick bait you got the views
but people realize you were a hypocrite
it's like yeah that's true I think that
was my mistake is that I was more
focused on making podcast content than
about like really thinking about the the
full implication of what I was doing and
so on this point I totally agree with
you go kanaru give Bill Clinton called
out Donald Trump for being a sexual
deviant your point was just immediately
invalidated even if it's right plus you
even pathetically tried to bring items
into the mix and say that you would
understand if people criticized him and
first of all there I understand people
who had criticized I don't say that's
[ __ ] up the way you use it so
basically you're admitting that you
would understand if people criticize you
but you don't because you're a hypocrite
in your mind anyway back to old Kris
buying a gun so ok so that's a no this
part I'll skip forward he goes and buys
a gun and he's getting ready to kill me
he's there playing around with guns and
pointing it at their heads I just got
I'm gonna be honest with you dude the
sketches are pretty well here let me let
me show you
you know that's what the schedule is
like yeah well a whole eight month Oh
okay so chapter four is dance monkey
dance
exciting Oh surprise call right before
we move on to the next chapter we have
pewdiepie felix is actually gonna call
him to discuss the ordeal so let's throw
it to Felix and we have Felix here
actually here not a meme he is here and
to prove it I have no excuse actually
well people actually don't know what
really happened it was just it was no so
what I think what happened was that when
you were gonna call in but you were busy
you've done all kinds of [ __ ] and it was
full didn't really busy that's right
yeah that's time I do really want to
come on better circumstances well what
happened was he we had Connect a
tentative date and then he had something
came up and so I had already announced
it so everyone will kept being like what
happened to PewDiePie
so we just kept the meme going like
PewDiePie couldn't make it today what
today he is here and we're nearly the
payoff so how does it how does it feel
to have that dagger in your back I'm
still pulling out inch by inch every day
it's so deep no but seriously the pot I
made this podcast about you using the
n-word and I will say I made a whole
podcast about it I'm more curious of
what you have to say about it first at
least okay sure I made a whole podcast
about it we'll have to dagger we'll pull
it out at the end of the segment yeah
let's leave it in for now I made a whole
entire podcast about it and I feel like
that was way over the top I think at
most it warranted if I wanted to talk
about it like like a short commentary
but the whole whole podcast about it cuz
I've only seen like a small clip of it
well there was a whole podcast about it
and we brought eat that [ __ ] for 45
who's a really funny youtuber who's
black to comment on it which which by
the way he said he wasn't offended by it
and I knew that
I'm absolved you know what what he said
was that you made a heartfelt apology
and he thought you were sincere so it's
all good
and that was kind of what what I said -
yeah okay
I guess like in a way I didn't expect
you to you guys to defend or anything
because I admitted that it was wrong as
well like that was my apology as well so
that's just kind of how I felt about it
well regardless I do feel like I that
podcast was definitely a mistake and I
should have just kept my mouth shut and
clearly I wasn't trying I don't know if
that was necessarily the case like I I
don't think just like even if your
friends you can still criticize I know
what I did was wrong the whole podcast
was was definitely a mistake and I do
apologize for stock piling on you I mean
if anything I was so overwhelmed at the
time and I remember seeing it and people
are just mad right away and I'm like low
key just like okay I'm glad some
attention is away from me at this point
yeah there you guys see that's some real
French yeah I didn't really process it
that much either I didn't watch the
podcast i watch it now again just to get
refreshed on it but it is what I said
earlier like I know what I did was wrong
so I didn't expect people to be like no
he was right cuz I that's that was my
sentiment either well there you have it
in short what do we take away from this
people in the end really like to get mad
for other people's sake I get that a lot
that is true yeah yeah what do you what
do you think about people who are super
angry and then fans kind of do it for
you I feel like this is a thing that's
been going on for so long like it's been
like when was it 2018 yeah yeah it's
been a while
yeah it just feels a bit drag like I
wish people when would kiss stop
bringing it up altogether I just want to
move on yeah amen brother
yeah me too that was part of my no I
it's my [ __ ] too yep
III agree I'd look at the time I thought
there was like some
nuance about how I was saying it in the
context of a conversation about it
it is a bit it is different yeah but
like ultimately is a tough argument yeah
it's not at that point to begin it's not
it's it's too nuanced of an argument to
make to to really yeah exactly exactly
so obviously it was a mistake I do love
you I think you're a terrific guy Felix
and I think you are jacked you've got
six rock-hard aesthetic floor gang oh
yeah and I'm a fully torqued for you all
right okay Tiger out all right all right
dude
thank you very much for calling in I
appreciate you and I wish I wish you
well god bless you god bless you alright
remember we talked about jontron yeah
well a whole eight months after he lost
his sponsorships and you know he was
basically ridiculed off the internet
well you had it on your podcast
oh you've always been incredibly
generous and gracious friend to us
tonight genuinely loved it's been too
long now that I'm officially you know
guest number eight six hundred thousand
and five just kidding you see that
reaction like that signals to me that
jontron wasn't really welcome on the
podcast so again this is like this crazy
speculation okay like John first of all
we've been trying to get him on the
podcast since the beginning he lives in
New York we live in LA this we got him
on the first time he came to LA John
knows that we would have him at any day
he would just say but he and that's just
so not true he makes it sound like um
that's just the speculation yeah it's
total speculation it's totally not true
also this was well after the controversy
- I mean not it wasn't like right after
[Music]
on I think that's the link but it Sun
represents LaShawn actually that should
take you there sorry I never did like
merge before really so we have a link in
the chat to your store they're linking
in the chat great no cool awesome thanks
guys infamous debate oh [ __ ] what
happened so after eight and a half
months everybody's basically forgot
about it
now you give jontron a platform to
defend himself well I mean you know if
you and John John didn't want to come on
do it yeah it's just this whole part is
like pure speculation that's it's edited
to make the whole thing even worse yeah
we like full podcast and yeah looking
way too deep into some like facial looks
like oh he's like you see right there he
only brought it back on a like whoa
reading end is beforehand for him to
discuss it then that makes sense that's
fine well good because we did we had a
long conversation I'll give a background
here
about it now you give jontron a platform
to defend himself well I mean you know
if you and John agreed to do this
beforehand - for him to discuss it then
that makes sense that's fine it happened
how long ago so why do you assume that
we did it right of course we did I
wanted to do that to him just just
kamikaze him like that we actually had
like on a personal level we had a lot of
conversations about it before because we
were hanging out the whole day before
the podcast and we had kind of discussed
about what we wanted to save because I
wanted to help him kind of guide the
comer because we had a really productive
conversation and I was trying to guide
him and what a way that I thought would
help explain what he said and so when we
were on the podcast I think John kind of
just clammed up a little bit and I kept
I think in my mind I was trying to help
bring him to the point where we were off
and yeah because yeah I remember the
conversation before we were kind of
going over some things then he was
talking to us like the kind of things
that he wants to say on the podcast it's
kind of like a little bit of a
pre-interview yeah so then on the
podcast I think he you kept trying to go
back to those yeah but he kind of
changed so I guess you didn't want to go
there yeah and so the failure for sure
is on my part of being a bad host but to
speculate that it's malicious is just
it's not true I mean it's just not true
but I definitely own that that I was not
reading the room and I should just moved
on long before that let's watch though I
mean I haven't shown you the club okay
was that no I don't keep track we're
this is just John's
I feel like that's just John the way
that is like moving and talking but he's
reading so much into it well he's saying
we didn't even speak to John for animals
but we speak all the time we haven't
seen John in nine months because we
moved to LA and he lives in New York
yeah things like you don't have to
comment at all like I don't really want
to get into this it's a minefield of
sorts I'm not gonna go back in it pick
everything
and just so you know this is super cut
up and I don't know if this came in the
beginning or the end or what and
qualified or anything I'm not really
gonna get into it but oh yeah I guess
the main question on everyone's mind is
all easy race this is he a Nazi no I
treat every single person with the same
respect they afford me
that's basically my full statement okay
I mean did you say do you feel like you
said some things that you regret so this
is what I'm doing now I'm trying I'm
like well we had a good conversation and
I felt like if you can explain yourself
a little better maybe people understand
where you're coming from but obviously
didn't come off that way and it's funny
at the time there was like this
incredible pressure on me to to address
John about that and then after the video
people were angry that I let him off
easy and now it's time has passed and
they forgot the context of that episode
now it's easy to look back and be like
Oh Ethan was too hard on him which is
just it's ironic because that's not what
happened did you have a lot of
self-aware moments during that time I
was like if they're drunk was i drinking
eyes I'm not the person to fight this
battle right no well let me just say for
the record like that I I disagree with a
lot of stuff you said I don't I just
don't want I really don't want to get by
the way that's cut okay
right so what I was saying is while I
disagree with what you said I'm still
your friend because you don't understand
the amount of tension that was a Ripper
surrounding that episode like we pulled
up the thread when we put we used to put
up threads for our guests to write
questions and the thread that we put up
for John was all about this issue and so
I wanted to make it very clear that like
while we disagree on on these points
that I'm still friends and I and I don't
because the the hate towards John during
that time was insane
and so I'd be like yeah
I disagree with you but I still love you
and we're we're still friends I mean I
make this point that if I just cut you
out of my life what does that accomplish
how are we ever gonna learn and evolve
from that which I would never deal it's
just hypothetical again this I'd like to
move on as quickly as possible because I
just really don't end this I don't want
I'm a committee I'm not trying to go
back into this I just treat people with
the same respect they give me at the end
right don't want to hurt anyone yeah
it's just that's me don't want to get
into it past that okay not sure let's
treat people with the same respect they
give me at the end right don't want to
hurt anyone yeah system that's me don't
want to get into it past that okay the
face when you want to rip your friends
spleen out of his chest in front of
20,000 live viewers is that the fate I
don't know that that's that face
specifically the spleen
you can tell no that's okay I kind of
wanna ask you tell me if you don't want
to talk about yeah Ethan I don't think
he wants to talk about it right yeah I
should have definitely just moved on
that's for sure ask you stuff that I
find that's my problem with this the
general theme of this video is basically
to me what it shows is just moments that
really showed our lack of experience is
yeah we're not happy with those moments
too and we need we continuously try to
work on everything and try to improve
sure I mean this is episode 30 okay so
obviously we've I think we've gotten a
lot better
at hosting a show obviously I'm still
have a lot of learning to do I'm not as
good as I want to be I mean you look at
someone like Joe Rogan he was like 1,500
episodes you know what I mean so so I
still feel like I'm somewhat of an
amateur at doing this but um again I
just I understand how he could read into
it and see that but that lacking the
context of the episode and speculating
that I just blindsided him is not true
so me to do comi so I just clearly
I just get anyway you know what from it
let's just let's just throw it straight
to the man himself we have a call from
none other than jontron we have on the
phone with us jontron John hello god
bless you I sneeze thanks well you may
sneak and you could put that in the big
try what's up to be here and I so I'm so
enthused to comment yes I know John tell
me we didn't interview or we did an
episode together that was heavily
critiqued in which people had said that
I was very hard on you and I pushed you
too much and that we didn't talk about
it beforehand well I just want to know
what was your reaction to that episode
did they say that do they say that we
didn't talk about yes they speculated
that I blindsided you though we I've
been this for years now or I think it's
years I don't spin years right yeah so
I'm here for a long time now like I see
it in comments you know like um go
canarios video I remember when that came
out and everybody was saying those kind
of things in comments that's kind of
like I don't want to get in between this
it's just more blahblah on the internet
but you know if I kind of want to just
put it just smell some of the rumors at
least at least if people are gonna be
critiquing like let them do it on the
basis of acting stuff so or if people
want to be critiquing it let's let them
do it on the basis of what actually
happened so yeah I know we talked about
it beforehand like we met you didn't
blindside me basically I know that's
what basically you know that's been the
thing people have been saying that you
just kind of came at me and I didn't
know was coming but no we talked about
going over the topic it was too kind of
sensitive I think both parties were a
little bit like me and you and hila like
I don't know how to come at this here is
a short and tall of it me and Ethan and
he'll I go way back I know them very
well
like I know them on a personal level so
yeah we did talk about this thing
beforehand we knew would be awkward
it was our first suspect um but was was
it was
Malus blindsiding I don't think so I
know how could you say I don't think so
come on you know thank you close the
door on it done it doesn't sound like it
I don't think so you're not mean you can
decide whether you want to use this I
know that it wasn't malicious I'll tell
you why cuz even in HeLa graciously let
me stay at their house that same night
it's not like you just cut me loose into
the city and the next morning he was
like checking his reddit and he's
wondering if he did the right thing this
was not a situation of mal-intent
I can say that for a fact just to recap
we are friends I legit look the reason
I'm here you know I don't like to be in
this kind of thing but it's just because
I don't like seeing people slander you
went like I just mean like slander you
using my name when it's not true so
that's what thank you so much John thank
you why would I not you would do the
same for me I would absolutely I would
and he less sorry if you know what
you're behind my pictures like yours you
feel like you're not here but you are
here I'm here hello
sorry it's good to see you it's good to
see you all right Thank You Johnny I'll
talk to you bye thank you I saw this
podcast it made me realize that Ethan is
the Iago of YouTube
he isn't friends with you unless he has
something to gain you know maybe he's
friends like leafy friends you know like
that kind of friendship but unless you
have something directly to benefit him
you're not friends like seriously notice
how everybody who he openly claims to be
his friends every all the friends he
includes in his video ty Lopez that's
fine by the way jontron is is just as
famous as anyone here all right I don't
understand that point by the way jontron
is my dear friend he's probably close
with my closest friend
as close as any of these fields Lopez
though I've opened up there we're
successful okay it's cuz he's
opportunistic by Nature
I don't you know I don't that's that's a
strange one I have to say people always
gravitate the other fellows and in like
a similar stratosphere so it's just
because you have more to relate to say
that I'm that I'm a opportunistic like I
mean me and I dubs our friends we've
made a lot of content together I mean I
have I do have non famous friends of
course but what do you want me to say
about them dude you want me to tell you
all I ever want to hang out with and no
Ethan is the Iago of YouTube but if you
look at like a man's with you unless he
has something to gain who he oh I don't
even know that I should blame him but I
will because he is I mean I I genuinely
don't think he has ever collabed with a
smaller youtuber you know take that how
you will he has no obligation to but it
says something considering how many
friends he has in the community but sure
he'll have John on the podcast after not
talking to him for eight months but we
don't know why that is because he wanted
the fresh scooped he wanted the juicy
details he wanted John that's not why
people watched it it's not fresh either
yeah but also a lot of our podcasts have
views like that from that from like that
age you know it's not it's not unusual
trying to explain to everybody how he
got those [ __ ] up ideas in his head
and this is classic I mean this is not a
one-off situation watch the podcast for
so long and you'll definitely notice
something you might not notice it
directly but anytime Ethan feels he's
superior tous guest he makes it
blatantly obvious one of the worst
occasions of this is the episode with
Jimmy Lee I'm gonna try and make this
brief but if you do watch this podcast
episode it is insane the amount of
disrespect that Ethan displays for this
okay so it's up this part I have to
admit is just so funny to me because he
clearly has no idea who Jimmy Lee is he
thinks he's just some random some random
dude Ian that I some random comedian
that had Jimmy Lee let me give you some
backstory Jimmy Lee cuz
I have to go back again to the hours and
hours of research comment because again
either you didn't do that much research
or this is a bad faith argument because
the origin story of Jimmy Lee is that a
fan at the top here I pulled this up the
fan wrote us an email
they said this is my actual dentist I
discovered this video when I decided to
look up his alter-ego Jimmy Lee a name
which is displayed on top of his music
album that he gives to his patients it's
the dumbest [ __ ] thing in the world
this video makes me want to claw my eyes
out so Jimmy Lee is a dentist who gives
his mixtapes to his nation and this was
during the time we were doing eatin in
the other videos yeah and people kept
posting submissions for us to react to
and that's how it started we reacted to
this video that they sent here so Jimmy
Lee makes these incredible videos like
sketches we show an example they're all
super black racist - she says something
about she thinks he's gay and she
doesn't want to be next to him or
something and it's just all super crude
she's got like a look yeah exactly it's
awesome so anyway that's how we found
out Jimmy Lee and then we started having
this back and forth with Jimmy he became
like this beloved meme and that Ethan
and ela universe to the point where we
actually collabed with him which goes
against your original claim by the way
that I'd haven't collabed with any small
youtubers Jimmy Lee was a small youtuber
and we made a video with him here's a
excerpt from that this is one of the
greatest moments ever
so we met Jimmy Lee when we were living
in New York and we just made kind of
like a vlog together getting to know him
because he's such a character and I
cannot emphasize this enough Jimmy Lee
is a character unlike anybody else in
the world here we are
eating lunch and just watch him start
he's married by the way and watch him
start hitting on this waitress
Wow unscripted uncensored and that's
what people he's just this absolutely
incredible character right but like I
mean let me just put this up here this
is suiting here's another one of one of
his videos he does Street comedy and
here he just called he just calls people
fat I mean it's incredible that he gets
away with it
you believe that [ __ ] he just goes up
people and cause him fat and now he
called these girls ugly Freddy Krueger
[Music]
you know soon as he leave yeah there's a
bunch he does grace this job he does it
all man he's the whole song and dance I
wish I had some racist jokes
time-stamped but like this guy has just
figured out how to say and do anything
and people just I don't know standing
right there I think I mean it's that age
too it's just a different generation
dude it's great and then he cruises
around by the way when he's doing the
street comedy with like he hires models
to walk around with them it's awesome
kids go to private school they won't
tell me where it is I'm funny threesome
list that I use both hands
anyway that's Jimmy leave like this is
he acts like Jimmy is just some random
sweet old man that we came we came in
and just decimated or something but I
mean come on it's Jimmy leave you you
don't know anything about Jimmy Lee bro
and you're talking about it it's crazy
it's crazy that you're that you're
defending safety I mean it's crazy dude
I don't have to say it's crazy like it
really genuinely is but okay let's watch
what he has to say about Jimmy's first
occasion the episode he opens the
podcast by basically bashing him and
discrediting him as a comedian his
comedy style you didn't watch the show
the clip you didn't even show the clip
actually roasting people he's never met
before I mean Jimmy emails me very
frequently Jimmy by the way does even to
this day he emails and texts mm-hmm on a
daily basis frankly every boy loves
forgive me for it he's a character
wasn't personal but I endured it because
I'm like Jimmy's a legend I mean the
guy's the guy's a legend so and Jimmy
he's a legend then after talking [ __ ]
about him he welcomes a month the
podcast I mean wasn't that much [ __ ]
okay
by the way the whole relationship we
have with him is talking [ __ ] on him
we've made like four videos on him on
the Ethan inch ela channel they're all
[ __ ] on Jimmy Lee that's the whole
premise of our relationship that's it's
basically he does cringy comedy and
that's how we found him no he's not is
the relationship you know it's not like
it's not like he's unaware of it that's
the whole purpose he wants to be with us
he wants to do interact with us knowing
that we're always just goofing on him so
so so why should i that's that's the
expectation he had coming in but it's
all fine it's all we're good yeah it's
with peace and love yeah for sure
welcome the legend to be kind of you
know a decent guy and everything they
create an effect God and an illusion is
really what it is right so it's a
marketing tool okay by the way that we
told Jimmy because we knew he's gonna
pull some [ __ ] cuz he's such a character
he we told him no can't you can't I
don't want you to bring a camera in the
podcast studio because it's small and
it's distracting and then sure enough we
start recording and this camera guy
slips in the door after we started
reporting not one there was one guy
there was so it's so like it I agree
it's awkward so live show but like guy
like for me every time I was looking at
Jimmy the guy was here like trying to
take pictures I was like I can't talk to
you when the guys are part of me so I
mean it's easy to point Ella as being
like [ __ ] or something but like again
we said don't bring the cameras in and
then there was two camera guys they came
it I'm like Jimmy just used I was like
just use the footage from the pocket we
told them you could we yeah you can have
all the footage they're getting right in
their face yeah we have three cameras in
here
but it's hard for me to focus on you
when they went out good oh can you stay
and do stills we took photos together
okay
this is pretty much what we expected
though it's part of the experience for
sure and for some reason this
interaction gives Ethan the green light
to just [ __ ] ruin this guy's day like
it's it's no again I you I don't even
know that's based on nothing that's just
your narrative your hours of research
didn't even take take you down to Jimmy
Lee hole you don't even know our
relationship I mean that's just a bad
faith argument to show Jimmy Lee secret
like between us is that it's it can be
awkward for people to be around you
right like you know that you elicits
that response why why do people who'd
you have dude you have to go watch the
video I made with him he's you don't
understand that is his existence like to
say that that was the green light for me
to [ __ ] on Jimmy Lee just approves this
is a bad faith argument he focuses
heavily on the fact that his jokes are
dated and they're kind of racist in a
way and oh my god did you see that look
at this my god Ethan so we just got a
good look at the Google Doc he uses to
question this guy and wouldn't you know
it it outlines every single question he
asks for me and I got a big outfit and
you're successful dentist what is your
passion is a comedy or dentistry well I
wasn't doing this for money I'm not
making money doing it it's a passion
from here so what does your wife think
about that she thinks I'm nuts and I got
my older son that thinks I'm nuts and my
young one thinks I'm hysterical what
does she think about all the female
attention you get it even has some of
the [ __ ] jokes that he uses jimmy
emails me very frequently he pretty much
emails me like five times we're best
friends
he knows hila too so now we know why you
so pushy during the jontron interview
when he has an agenda well okay I mean
this criticisms just strange that I have
notes yeah I mean the why why is that a
criticism I mean I'm an amateur podcast
host and I try to formulate my thoughts
as best I can I mean I agree that it's
best I
learned that it's best to be prepared
but to avoid it as much as possible
that's what I've learned over time yeah
you don't script it nearly as close and
we have experiment we've experimented
with different ways to it's just this is
all a learning experience for us but
we've done once like that and then we've
done ones with no notes to see how Josa
conversation goes but I don't see why is
that here in the video that's just I
don't either and I mean I accept the
criticism of course that I'm not a good
podcast host and I'm deaf I'm always
trying to improve but it's almost like
he just saw like my notes and he's like
oh I can expose I can use this in some
way to show like I found something out
that I wasn't supposed to see but
there's really nothing incriminating
about me wanting to have notes I mean
I'm just trying to be prepared he just
goes with it he doesn't give a [ __ ] he
doesn't even listen to what the people
are saying he asks the questions he
wrote down and doesn't even care to
transition them properly that's kind of
a personal yeah that's true I mean that
that's probably true that that
especially at that time that that I was
too reliant or wasn't you know engaged
my fear as a podcast host is like that I
was I'm back then I had this issues like
I don't want dead air and my fear is
that they'll stop talking and I won't
know what to say right so I was always
trying to load up the next question in
my mind because it's like this you want
to keep the show flowing but you also
want to have a natural conversation so
this was kind of what I was balancing
with and especially doing it live added
an extra layer of making it stressful
right because it's live and every little
like I don't know you notice it
immediately and it's awkward yeah back
then - I want to point out that we not
only were we doing it live but you guys
would always have the twitch chat open
right in the show yeah which we realized
was a terrible idea because you're being
way too receptive - yeah feedback and I
remember during that Jimmy Lee episode
it was just a wall of people saying oh
my god this is so uncomfortable this is
so cringe Bob you know like and that
gets in your head right and
so I mean that was that was a mistake as
well yeah it's a convenient for him that
he goes I'm just gonna talk about this
real fast because yeah because you
haven't you don't have any context you
don't actually show any of the episode
and you're just painting this whole
narrative and speculating on [ __ ]
there's just a hundred percent untrue I
mean the only thing that is true that
I'll own and that you're right about is
that I was and still am a bad podcast
host but is that really enough to say
that I'm a bad dude what would you think
this video is trying to say I mean I
don't see how that me Quast me being a
bad person
bündchen right because who would do this
that's why I don't get and have fun
that's by doing this viewers what's at
the script Jimmy how long have you been
Wyatt
I'll be black with you in a minute
that's serious like this holder let's
keep watching man this videos of cherry
picking the parcel they can look bad you
do that's you've gotta watch his videos
bro what you haven't no content the fact
that you're gonna come out here and and
be sad for Jimmy Lee is so mental bro
it's such a bad faith argument just go
watch the videos bro nothing's
cherry-picked is spectacular okay
older people only reason the kick and
mouth failed is because you wanted it to
you wanted to rag on this old man and
you succeed oh he's no angel okay when
this guy goes to the bathroom she
[ __ ] literally suggests that they
kick him out saying we could bring
bandwidth in years after the break and
Ethan loves and again you like people on
the chat we're going like get him out of
there so again we were reacting to that
I agree with super awkward
and honestly we probably shouldn't
kicked him out but like whatever it was
just really uncomfortable is a really
early episode it's for planning all
around yeah it was a bad execution yeah
it needed to be planned out more as
here's this segment and here's that it
was a transition but it was all alive
and it's like okay how do we talk about
how we want to move forward not right
now while it's also live and we don't
know what we
doing but this whole thing he's just a
poor old man is so crazy it's just so
bad an argument it's just it is and I
don't know how much Jimmy Lee would
appreciate being referred to as some old
man anyway either like it's weird cuz
gokhan ro has this way of insulting the
people he's trying to defend like he
freaking won you'll see when we get to
shoenice he's always going he's just a
drunk he's he's this alcoholic drunk and
like he just writes some office and it's
I find it very bizarre I found a very
demeaning the way he refers to these
people as some old man some old man
Jimmy Lee the jersey outlaw because he
goes through with it he does it guys I'm
sorry
[Music]
thanks for joining us today I was a it
was a pleasure I hope you'd finish like
with like the guy was racist that his
jokes were there were clearly jokes
we're racist and then five minutes guy
leaves he says this the old guy leaders
for banning dabbing there it is that was
like a [ __ ] jihad dad that was like
[ __ ] straight-up Akbar dad here we go
we're going in slow-mo no wind up that
was a brutal damn wasn't that about how
they banned dabbing in Saudi Arabia or
some [ __ ] oh no I don't think that they
banned it that was so long ago that was
a really brutal dad boy keeps refracted
then - as an employee if you've done
your research
this is dead again
the producer it's got a name yes anyway
I treat my answer will die just treat
people with the same respect they give
anyway we've talked about Jimmy Lee now
let's hear what Jimmy Lee has to say and
we welcome to the show Jimmy Lee the
jersey outlaw and with us today we have
Jimmy Lee the Jersey outlawed can you
hear me Jimmy are we doing a gag we're
doing a gag all right is that it that's
it thanks for joining us yeah be nice to
see ya how you been to get my prostate
checked and I said where do I put my
pants he said next to mine I left nice
how you been how you good good good good
I've missed those those beautiful
one-liners our podcast episode we did
together how did you feel about that
episode I mean did you feel that I was
rude to you there well there were a lot
of comments that you were
and then I get I guess I got asked to
leave but didn't figure it out to the
end and I never had a problem with you
but I think people that watch they did
and some people said you're mean and
some people said I mean it was like
catch-22 but me being a performer I know
you mock me and I mock people when I'm
on the street and you know I don't take
that personal because that's part of the
act and you know being an entertainer
you have to roll with that so did you
want fresh material it's always fresh
all your material is fresh you want
might you want a new joke give me
whatever you like well I was with an
orphan girl and I made love and then
when I got done she said she want to go
to church to find her father no good
just took me a mom I was processing she
went to church to find her father being
God right well father meaning she
doesn't have a father and she Laura in
the church yeah it's a lot to chew on
that's a good job giving me trouble
she's giving me trouble mm-hmm my wife's
giving me truck I took her to the
Presidential Suite at Motel 6
Hilla and we're making love and I said
honey why so quiet and she said I'm in
the bathroom you idiot and I said stay
there I'm doing better without you we're
not talking now that's this game here
that there was even a round bed above
the round mirror above the bed it's an
object may appear larger than the action
you are and so right of course and and I
told her she's a lousy cook I said if
you could cook better we could fire this
chap she said if you could screw better
we could fire the chauffeur you see or
fighting the wife and I if you could
screw better we could fire the chauffeur
yeah and so she's a chauffeur right yeah
well I told her she said no I said is
that your final answer she said yes so I
phoned a friend that's when the fight
started well that makes sense if you
shouldn't be calling other women Jimmy
so I'm still doing my thing well thank
you for giving us a call it was great to
see you
this was great though you got some great
material mm-hmm thanks for having me on
you guys have a wonderful night thank
you thank you thank you thank you bye
now superiority complex
okay so Jimmy we had a very small
following if any at all so Ethan felt
that he could act that way toward him
and he would get minimal backlash that's
just again come on dude but what happens
when he treats another youtuber with
disrespect well this is William Osmond
he's an engineer who makes very creative
and very interesting videos now a while
ago his house actually burned down and
obviously that was a pretty you know
devastating experience for him but one
of the projects that he was working on
was a beanie that talked and it was made
for Ethan specifically and that video
garnered a lot of attention and finally
after about five months
William was invited onto the podcast
however there was one small little issue
with Williams Channel he only had
600,000 subscribers
again that's speculating and my issue
okay that's not even really a small
Channel yeah I don't think so either
yeah to support the argument but again
like you look back at all of the
youtubers that have been on Ethan's
podcast there's not a single one with
less than a million subscribers I just
this whole argument right there captain
captain disillusion by the way we
literally I love this guy we flew him
out and put him in a hotel so we could
put him on so I mean first of all you're
factually wrong habit Eric from internet
comment and air ticket we should say -
you should check I had seen one of the
many follow-up videos that this guy has
done him acknowledged that that was a
mistake okay but so he took full
disclosure like he's aware of that that
is a false statement ma'am whatever
I mean it's we're reacting to the video
that these people are not watching his
follow-up oh I agree I'm just giving him
but he is included always with
jacksFilms it's not true we had to Eric
on so many times without jack we had him
on like more than anybody yeah obviously
has a lot of subscribers
he's kind of supplementary you know and
as well Eric obviously is well known for
bouncing on his boys dick I did nothing
wrong
come the [ __ ] on it's not a
multi-layered [ __ ] issue don't say
the n-word
yeah but other than Eric William was the
first person to be invited on to the
podcast with less than a million subs
you know for once I opened the doors for
someone who was up and coming so why do
I see me as an issue yeah what about
Jimmy Lee just at all he wasn't given a
full episode he was given a 20-minute
time space on an episode they said we're
gonna be on for like 20 minutes
yeah we did he's not really a creator
though he's more like internet folklore
I guess so he says so by the way I
didn't know that William made this video
before he came on although it's good at
least cuz he acknowledges that we he
knew what he was coming for and the
reason that he only was coming for 20
minutes if you look at that episode was
only an hour long and I think the reason
is that again like we did so many times
is we're experimenting and trying things
my idea was like let me try it where we
do this segment with William and then we
do the news and that's the whole episode
it was only an hour long I think there
was another segment before William came
into but hmm but yes we were trying to
do a more segmented yes like a talk show
word and so actually I didn't know that
he had that he was sad that he wasn't
gonna get a full episode and I and I do
feel bad that we didn't give him a full
episode and we definitely should have I
agree with that a million percent
totally but it wasn't malice that's what
I want to say it wasn't out of malice it
was really just out of I was
experimenting with different things on
the podcast and I was up was thoughtless
I mean I'll say that for sure I but but
malice is I mean that's just not true
I'm like a temperate I don't know you
know saying like supplemental so
whatever your show so what we've learned
is that we're not excited and when you
were so well again I didn't even know he
made this video if I did I would have
give him the full episode watch the
episode there is very little substance
to this hour-long episode of the podcast
and William could have easily filled
that time when this is a very mediocre
episode we're just sitting here you know
everybody that's not a slight at William
we said that all of our yeah episodes
during that time it was a joke I'm it's
like this is the best episode no this is
a very mediocre up so let me be upfront
with you but okay whatever you know 20
minutes is still better than no time at
all right so let's just see what they
talk about though the story of this
being a excretion is also interesting
one interesting a nice word for tragic
one I'll show you the fridge howdy
what's the process like of like okay you
go to the site
everything's gone mm-hmm like what what
do you do it's a very lost feeling it's
not a good it's imagine everything
stripped away you don't know what you're
doing the next day you don't know what
you're doing the next week you don't
know anything and what's the like the
thing that you you really were depressed
about losing that maybe you didn't
expect but it wasn't having like into
everything instantaneously as you do
every day so for the sake of saving you
some time they basically just talked
about how his house burned down for a
good 15 minutes of his 20 minutes and
obviously you know if this were a
full-fledged podcast then it would make
sense for them to go on about this for a
while but he only has 20 minutes so
basically the majority was time was
spent talking about a devastating
situation he endured and to their credit
Ethan in Hilo seems like they do care
but immediately after this they
transition swiftly so just again to give
context he had his like he had a really
viral video because he made a video
about on his channel his house burned
down we're both from Ventura
incidentally so it was like following
that whole story and he made a video
about his house burning down and going
through the rubble that went like super
viral so I mean to me it seemed like a
really interesting topic of
conversations I also it this is a small
point but I do want to say just because
he keeps saying it it was longer than 20
minutes mm-hmm
okay so again for all that research it's
just like kind of fudging the number
right how long was it like 25 minutes I
think it was a little bit longer than
that even it was close to a half hour
okay
so 27 but like obviously you know you're
rounding down yeah to make it about the
talking beanie well I'm happy that you
made it out
me too I mean you said you really saved
the most important you've got the vania
I'm not joking I this really was high on
my party but not specifically because of
you but because it was the video yeah it
was for you let me try this thing on
let's let's oh I'm gonna turn the facts
turn it up I don't see any problem here
I mean I'm just doing it so I'm scared
what's it matera you're come promise I
have seen anyway thank you god bless his
other video too about the Vin Diesel
thing so I don't really know it'd be
perfect but Ethan doesn't care to
collaborate with people who are below
him he only looks above and it's a bad
[ __ ] idea because you're gonna end up
getting hit hard with a lot of people
realizing that you don't care all right
god bless man thanks just speculate how
would you I mean we chose to talk about
what we cared about that's our show you
yeah all right I don't really see
anything wrong with this part I think
he's stretching really far here on 2d
god damn freaking Ian's beat this was
great we did you say that we just posted
a video so I was so right now we're
having a really awkward moment and that
alone because again we we were just
starting I think Dan had recently
started and we hadn't really figured out
like how to do C changes and stuff and
we had planned that we would move on and
do the news thing but William didn't
really know if he was should stay there
or if I should move out Dan was gonna
come in or Dan was gonna come and do the
news I don't think is that correct I
think it was actually Ian or Ian I don't
remember the ian was new it was one of
the first times we were bringing in Ian
for a segment wasn't when we went to the
Kanye thing right now I'm almost certain
that's what it was well it doesn't
matter what
load this oh is it this is this why you
oh this this is awkward I agree this on
our table yeah the videos up but at best
we'll put it was a video I don't know
what's happening it's very awful you
would think that after 60 plus in stepa
so they would be better at transitioning
guests I agree that's legitimate for
hink sure we were still alive at the
time we got a two-shot do you guys mind
swapping out that's fine this is Ian or
William god bless you everybody please
check out Williams Channel I'm gonna put
a link in the description yeah please
leave that alright it is still there by
the way broken ok get Bobby Lee remember
come on come by the way we only had
three chairs in there so we didn't have
another camera set up yeah it was poorly
thought out I'll take the blame for that
the thing is that dissipate we literally
couldn't have four people in here and do
the new segment what I should have done
is just continued to talk to him but
like I had this idea anyway yeah it was
awkward but there was no mouse they put
the guy's name it he is a [ __ ]
significant following 600k is not
nothing man so wait is he and
significant or is he big you can't make
up your mind about him anyway the
viewers picked up on this very easily
and the title was changed although for
some reason the booty dr. description
was extended so you can't see his name
and recommended and I do think that this
lack of respect that is displayed by
Ethan is largely to do with this [ __ ]
micromanaging of the podcast we saw
already that he has scripts for his
podcasts and his questions and clearly
this is causing issues because he sticks
too closely to his shitty scripts you
know this is a fan and a fellow youtuber
who was very excited to come on and
rather than exploring his mind you just
you you limited him to two things beanie
and [ __ ] fire this also kind of
explains why the bill bird podcast went
so poorly oh well before we get into
Bill burr we have a call from yours
truly
William Osmond welcome back to the show
so William thank you for joining us
how how did you feel about the video you
know I never saw the video you made
before you came on the show where you
were saying that you were disappointed
you were gonna be on for 20 minutes and
I do want to say right off the bat that
I should 100% have given you your own
episode at the time we were trying to
like segment did and I was trying to do
so awkward it was very awkward and I
should have given you your whole episode
no I mean I I think that like I don't
honestly at the end of the day like I
don't really care I think people make a
bigger stink about it then they should
yeah like I think that you know you you
know nobody's perfect and I think that
you Neela are like some of the nicest
people that I've met and the decision to
not have me on longer probably stemmed
from maybe not thinking that it would be
like as interesting to the the podcast
audience which I totally get like as a
content creator you have to try to
figure out what people want to see and
so I think it was just a kind of
unfortunate situation where you know it
may have been deemed that that people
didn't want to see as much of William
Osmond stuff because at the time it was
you know it was a much smaller Channel
so it's not it's not like something that
has affected me greatly like I don't
think about it every day at the time
though it was maybe a little bit of a
bummer to have not been included more
but that doesn't really you know change
the way like you guys have I've you know
been nice to me you've been like
especially that day after well I do
definitely apologize we should have
included you in the whole episode for
sure yeah that's it that's really all
there is to it but actually you are
coming next week yeah next Friday you
will be in the studio for about 20
minutes and then we'll have to move
no we're gonna do if we're gonna do the
fall episode we should have done back
then but awesome but well what else what
really else is there to say I I don't
think anything like I I think that
people just select a sort of weaponized
stuff that they see online and and to me
it's it's just it's not a big deal like
everything I do is like trying to be
creative and trying to entertain people
and like I've made decisions that you
know like I'm gonna show less of this or
more of that because that's I think
people want and and so there's there's
no hard feelings there's nothing that
you know like there's some stigma
there's no like I'm not mad at anybody
and never have been mad at anybody and
so I think you know that's that's
basically it I mean like other people
have talked about it online more than
I've ever even thought about it
right yeah it's well thank you for
saying that
and I do want to ask what is going on
with your hair you want to see let me
see a profile yeah I let my caretaker
cut my hair oh yeah oh yeah holy crap no
that's a quarantine with the beard and
everything I mean that's a quarantine
special I think it's a quarantine
special exactly she's ever given someone
a haircut I like went down to the to the
scalp on the side your fade was just us
trying to like you know communicate hey
like a fade is like a transition but it
was too late at that point
well it looks great I can't wait to see
that beautiful head with all the
attached hairs and everything and we'll
get into more detail on next week yeah
yeah perfect sounds good okay thanks for
thank you for calling in yeah all right
you guys all right bye-bye
welcome back now let's talk about Bill
burr this also kind of explains why the
bill bird podcast went so poorly but you
see the difference is that usually the
person who Ethan brings on is well aware
of who Ethan is and so Ethan feels a
degree of power right because he's this
authority figure I mean again it's
really just you're speculating a lot and
you're using Jimmy Lee and William
Osmond two of our first episodes that
they were awkward as proof that I am
exhibiting power over the guests
whatever but Bill burr doesn't know who
the [ __ ] Ethan is and he doesn't care
and Ethan went into it assuming that he
would already have respect he flashed
celebrate good if anything if you watch
back to bill burr I'm I'm I'm painfully
insecure if anything I mean yeah I have
incredible reverence for Bill burr and
so the fact that it was awkward was
really just me being nervous and and
being insecure what he doesn't mention
in this part is that Bill burr so I was
like wow okay he left and then Bill burr
reached out to us to come back on a
second time he reached out to us and the
second one everyone thought went great
they said it was the redemption episode
right that was well after he released
this video though oh it was okay so fair
enough to him yeah but but I don't know
you can watch this and then say I'm I'm
superior I mean I see the opposite
personally like he didn't have to earn
it but it's bill burr is a very grounded
guy and he [ __ ] shattered that
illusion and it was beautiful to see the
great bill burr here today all about
great give me something greatest guy
sitting across from you right now at the
NCAA there's a lot going on for the
great bill burr with the great great
what am i doing what way exactly
bill burr I'm flattered I do mean I know
it makes you uncomfortable but does one
great was bad enough but you know that I
like being appreciated yeah okay just
say Tony with the person I appreciate
yeah once again the great mine that's it
I appreciate very much
that's his finishing move well I love
that moment what did I do it on here you
do the great great as I turn around
thank you
where'd you uncomfortable now you [ __ ]
cop very very very funny gentlemen good
people good people yeah you are the
greatest greatest comedian I know
everybody and I don't I swear to God I
don't know but you know what I'm telling
man know what I'm gonna say I appreciate
you I was really anxious at the at the
time to be honest and I was like beside
myself with nerves with Bill burr being
here and so it was just him being you
know like the way it is if there's
another comedian on YouTube who has a
Pakistan YouTube called Theo von and
he's been on a show he's super funny
awesome dude and he had bill burr on
there and also like me Theo Vaughn's a
huge fan of Bill burr and Bill burr also
just totally railroaded him too and they
had like this really awkward think so
when I went when I went on Theo Vaughn's
show we were like just it was like the
bill burr anonymous Club like we were
all recovering but I mean this is not I
don't see me being superior I see me
just getting like being being very
insecure which is what I was you know we
don't the great billboard doesn't have
time for that right now I'm not ragging
on him for being nervous
I'm ragging on him because his
superiority complex was shattered
there's no evidence of that I didn't see
any evidence for that and it was
revealed that it's actually an
underlying layer of insecurity that is
driving him see yeah that's part of I
feel like that's a new thing you're
already worried about your daughter
being sexually assaulted you know how
old your dog I don't think that is I
think that's you you projecting your OCD
on me
it's you're talking about you know but
she said words and she totally
communicates cut up to I don't even know
what we were talking about yeah it's so
cut up but hearing you talk about her on
the podcast you're pretty perceptive
more than busting my balls and I was so
anxious that I couldn't appreciate the
fact that he was really just busting my
balls and fun
yeah and so I was like my mind was like
oh this is going awful and I was trying
and but I was like in my head you know
which is the worst while you're trying
to be in the moment but worst you could
say which bit plenty people did say is
that I'm a bad interviewer and this was
an awkward interview all that's true but
he's what he's doing and what he's
attempted to do throughout all this is
to speculate about what my intentions
are or what I meant and what I did but
none but it's not nervous true and
frankly I don't really think it's
supported by what he's showing either I
guess what he really does is he
establishes like my character really
early on which is funny because the
first thing with Leif he was flat-out
wrong and so with the leafy thing and
the jontron thing and all this then
you're like okay he's a really bad dude
and then you have no problem accepting
all the speculative things about my
intentions throughout the video really I
mean I just wanted for the sake of
brevity scholar and I know it's awkward
this feels like a child asking someone
questions on career day that's true when
you skip to the final box yeah press f
to pay respect for I've said this I went
on antidepressants the day of this I
went home and I [ __ ] literally that
was brutal yeah I'm just gonna keep
going superior inferior and now we have
bill burr on the phone no we don't oh
this parts great bonus coat here we G
sauce [ __ ] here and is ethan klein a
joke thief are you gonna do what hey
stre hey tree does where he goes against
his morals for financial gain and then
also life as viewers a lot as well
I'm sorry are you gonna are you gonna
steal content I don't know what he's
referring to but but didn't hear ideas
off other creatives and then use them as
your own and not shots yes okay
well according to Chad he is but Chad's
name is also anything for views so you
know doesn't exactly add credibility
Ethan stop stealing your jokes and stop
telling the same ones and you should be
good oh because you stole the vapenation
meme oh yeah tell it tell everyone
don't tell them where they start from
just say you stole yeah yeah the number
one gem of of ethan klein vapenation was
a stolen idea from a friend a close
friend to repeat it oh this is getting
spicy but like keep be honest like who
do you take it from why why are you
freaking Blue Boy holy weapon anxious
rhabdo oh yeah I don't know if I can
reveal that I'm not giving anyway
because I 3 bucks from real baby boo you
are Joaquim just gave it away I just saw
her in the Jack King gave it away
[Music]
okay I mean
Ethan's kind of already admitted that in
a way so well hero one day I was filming
with filthy Frank and his producer was
there and he was vaping so hard I was
like dog was going on with like this
vapor he said he's like yeah man it's
just it's vapenation and I was like wait
how's that wait say that again I was
like holy [ __ ] like that's brilliant
[ __ ] vapenation Chad Keane you tell
everyone what's going on here exactly
yep okay so first of all let me talk
about Chad anything for views I don't
know what this guy's problem is with me
but I've only met him once
okay he can
when keemstar came on this podcast he
came with him unannounced him and Andy
Milonakis
and I was going to the bat I didn't know
they were coming I was going to the
bathroom came star was already here I
was getting ready and then Chad walks in
the hallway and he goes he introduces
himself he goes hi I'm Chad I talk [ __ ]
about you all the time online and I was
like ok that's how he introduced himself
to me I says ok well I'm sorry that uh
you don't like me but welcome to my
office so then he comes in and they him
Chad and Andy sit outside what Kim
starts doing the podcast we have food we
served them it's very colder
cordial we have a good time we go
downstairs for a cigarette and he goes
so what tell me is it what is it true
that you stole vapenation from filthy
Frank this is before this by the way and
I say what I've never heard that before
that's I've never heard that before and
no I mean the whole videos improvised
right I mean how could I possibly steal
the everything in that video is 100%
improvised the two of us just out there
without a plan recording right and
that's the video the fact like the
outfit the character that was all
improvised we just literally took
clothes it was in our part man the one
thing that is true which is what I've
always admitted is that Topher George's
like he worked with them on the producer
side he said vapenation I know and
George never said anything about it and
I was like oh that's such a funny term
in fact Topher even helped me make the
video he helped us film the party yeah
the part in the Central Park when I was
doing a babe tricks Topher help me film
that and so and so I was like that that
doesn't make any sense it's all
improvised how could I even steal for me
he goes okay I just wanted to know
because that's what George says but
don't tell anyone but don't tell anyone
right and then okay well no it's not
true and then now he's out here telling
everybody like oh don't say anything
Ethan stole vapenation so I'm a joke
thief because I stole the title for a
fully improvised video okay and I now
and finally I was like I just called
George because I
frankly really offended and heard that
he was telling people that and I said
George is it true that you were tongue
telling people that I stole the idea for
vapenation I didn't even know that you
were planning to make a vape video I
didn't know I just heard Topher say
vapenation I don't know if he was
repeating you or what but and he goes
and he says that uh in short he says no
I'm gonna I'm gonna keep the
conversation the brief out of respect
for George but he said I did not say
that I've never said that so that's the
totality of this entire rumor that chad
has been spreading about me and I don't
know what's this [ __ ] guy's problem
why he always has such a hate boner for
me like but but what the [ __ ] I don't
know what to say to the guy I really
don't I mean he's friends with King star
so he's a right that's what he calls
himself
pat sit on him so that that's it so no
of course how can you steal something
that's totally improvised I mean it
doesn't make any sense so even after I
explained that to him he went and kids
kept spreading the rumor I don't really
know what what uh I don't really know
what else to say about that but okay you
know that just don't talk about it at
all because that's just straight drama
bro like what so why did you put it but
now you're talking about if you put in
your video also quick update my ex-wife
is now pregnant with my brother's child
Oh
Cass silver content baby why did he he
like started filming and didn't cut it
out when he had food in his mouth
pearl what what happened is spending
hundreds of hours editing you think
that's the part where you're still
chewing food I got to go back I'm sorry
but also quick update my ex-wife is now
pregnant with my brother's child
I'm sorry that I had to go back but just
please appreciate that he's eating foods
beginning in this clip in the park why
didn't he come back he should have spent
more hours at it
following Ethan's drunken rant about
keemstar he makes this comment by the
way the show I mean I I don't need I
don't need to clickbait
we're okay alright I'm not like
desperate for more clicks to put it ok
so I see a humble brag and a way for you
to deflect the criticism that you use
PewDiePie's controversy to kind of click
bait people and make them watch the
podcast but when somebody else brings up
your financial situation it's a little
different it's great now I'm so happy he
seems like you're doing all right for
yourself we got some walls we got some
courage trying why we're trying this
probe who's been to the hustle what's
this Mike's wait yikes
what yikes what did I say I'm not
getting the IKE sir you really didn't
like that what I was just goofing around
a genius to see you did not like that
Tim with that I think it does make good
genius apparently the most cringe thing
that has been in the video so far really
got him making a [ __ ] ton of money from
the podcast that would be crazy but
since John hit a soft spot there that's
nothing Ethan you started the podcast
because ad revenue was low there's
nothing wrong with that if you need
money to support yourself then get it
however you need just make sure your
content doesn't suffer but let me fill
you guys in on a little little juicy
detail a little little piece of mmm nice
meat do you want to know why Ethan his
focus so heavily on the podcast over the
last year why he hasn't made any
original content in the last four months
why his Twitter
now links to the podcast Channel yes the
Family Channel yeah it's because the
podcast makes a [ __ ] ton of money that's
one reason the other reason which I've
said many times is that I just lost
interest in making the same old video it
wasn't good I didn't like doing it I
just the reaction video format and the
criticism all that it's like it's a
constant search for looking for videos
and reaching for things to criticize I
didn't like it doing it any more I feel
like the whole thing became very
negative yeah this is the workflow at
home we started to not even enjoy the
process and then all of a sudden we were
working here and you get to go to an
office and you get to work with other
people yes and it gave us a stability it
felt like every week we know what we're
doing yes it's our decision I don't know
there were different reasons but I feel
like we just kind of moved on to
something else right we decided we
wanted to do this and I mean we spoke
about a lot but yeah but ultimately the
creative process became really toxic for
us and we just didn't enjoy the process
anymore so the podcast was more fresh
and exciting and fun and yes more
lucrative to which is all the more
reason to to continue to invest
ourselves in it let me let me break it
down for you hmm why is it that almost
every youtuber I know of has started a
podcast this year well the answer is
pretty simple they make money it's
because podcast can get direct sponsors
and direct sponsors make a lot more than
just a regular cons what kind of genius
analysis is those people make podcasts
because they make money here's where the
problem arises each episode of the h3
podcast has three to four spot no dude
have you ever watched a podcast they all
have that many in fact if you look at
like Joe Rogan or some of the really
popular ones they even have more like
five plus like Joe Rogan's attire the
first like 10-15 minutes is pure ads so
if you ever watch a television show you
how many have yeah right this is not a
high number but the thing is I mean just
for context though like I mean we are
definitely on par or even lower the most
popular podcast so it's weird too it's
just such a weird that
is insane it's not insane it's totally
it's the literal status quo sponsored by
me on DS movement naturebox and Dollar
Shave Club this episode is brought to
you because your sponsor making at least
$10 per thousand views at the [ __ ]
bare minimum then add pre-roll ads then
add the separate clips Channel and then
of course add you know the affiliate
links but when people actually you know
purchase products of affiliate links
I've never put affiliate links in my
[ __ ] description that that means that
what does it mean by that
we put oh he just means the URL yeah no
we don't we don't work on Commission
though oh I see what you're saying yeah
I thought he meant like a Amazon like
you put a like it that is technically
when an affiliate right I don't think
that's what he means
yeah I put I put up yeah I don't yeah
okay the industry podcast is making
conservatively $20,000 you can think I'm
full of [ __ ] but come on and the thing
is you think $20,000 is a lot because as
it appears that you're young man that I
mean I don't mean this as an insult it
just looks like you live with your
parents though I could be wrong about
that I'm not saying that to insult you
but we have three full-time employees
and we have an office just do the math
on that just like do a rough calculation
on that our costs $20,000 is not that
much money I mean it is it's a lot of
money right but but it's not I mean I
don't I don't I just uh but anyway what
what is I don't get the point of
counting our money like as a strike he
said you only put a hundred thousand I
said abso-fucking-lutely I put hundred
thousand on it goes to the winner winner
takes all
just think about it music let's say
average a million again conservative
that's a lot of people watching your ads
but nothing wrong with that just make
sure your content does not suffer that's
mean isn't that your objective opinion
subject yeah Yeah right subjective
because I stopped making h3 videos and I
started making the podcast that's the
equation
that's that's the trade-off make more
money do it how you need make better
content or at least the same degree
that's how I mean live your life how you
want don't tell me how to look my yeah
about that do whatever you want to do
that's the equation that who wrote ya
chop does it that's what you know most
relatively successful communities do the
videos improve over time but yours don't
you spend an average of ten full minutes
each podcast talking about your sponsors
you know instead of it's not ten minutes
I was like five well well we've had
times in the beginning that it took us
longer and we became better at doing
yeah definitely used to drag that's also
broadcasting I think we were trying to
goof it around and make it entertaining
so we'd make it longer and now we're
just snappier cuz I think people just I
understand that people who it's better
just get through it right now our ad
Rees are probably more like five max
like we know we read a five minute we
three yeah so but yeah like you said ela
that's totally normal three to five
minutes of ads in a two-hour podcast to
three-hour podcast back then we were
doing them longer and you know saving
people some time you drag it on you talk
about you Ram Justin he's making this
sinister music and he's talking about
how my ad reads are long this is this is
made it into his video but it with HeLa
is recorded completely separately of the
conversation as well so it's like a
legit commercial break a short short
break
we will be back soon with your boy
jontron thank you to me undies for
sponsoring this I'm not gonna watch me
thank you oh my god legitimate break in
the content and sometimes these breaks
are [ __ ] literally nine minutes long
such like in the ninja interview really
he was just do people want you're making
this like if people think it's too much
they could choose not to watch people
are watching the podcast it's just it's
so bizarre like we're just kicking it
you know gaming that's freaking awesome
yes thanks for watch guys we're gonna
take a short break we will be right back
welcome to running a business I don't
want to tell you do not go away do not
leave
dan cut me off we'll be right back after
this commercial break see you guys soon
they've got dr. cart you look like my
life at this point that I'm surprised
you don't shoot yourself every time you
[ __ ] ramble honestly good it's nuts
the amount it just flashed on screen 9
minutes of improvised Schilling one
thing I don't really think you know that
it's Schilling is usually when you're
you're being deceptive about like if
you're being paid to promote a product
but you don't disclose that like this is
all very upfront
I think Schilling just means like
selling out in the way he's using it I
guess yeah look you look like a cream
pie I care about you guys you know what
and wish the best for you Jesus
I really went on a tangent there like
man I've heard you ramble about Dollar
Shave Club so many [ __ ] times in my
eye I frankly okay life at this point
that's a weird point they don't shoot
yourself every time you [ __ ] ramble
honestly because it's nuts the amount of
time you've spent in your life talking
about Dollar Shave Club yeah they pay me
to talk about them dude nobody's paying
I mean look yeah they're a sponsor I
don't to say man you never listen to
radio or podcast or anything anyway so
now we understand why the main channel
has suffered so much it's because why
[ __ ] bother making high quality
content that takes you potentially
hundreds of hours to make when you're
gonna make like 500 bucks off the
Adsense you know why not exactly you
nailed it on the head [ __ ] that is one
point yeah I mean that's part of it
what's wrong with that - somebody or
talk to your wife who will barely
respond you know you'll make 20 to 40 k
yeah you know two hours no-brainer right
that's why the podcast is twice a week
it's so that he can make twice as much
money
wrong we did it twice a week because we
thought there for as long as we're
focused on the podcast let's do it more
frequently that also allowed us to
spread the ads over more episodes
basically do exactly what he's
criticizing tonight to have that brakes
be less we're gonna have four ads let's
do two a week exactly we didn't get more
it was too much I went back to one
actually well we went back to one when
the quarantine happened and the reason
is because I
did I I started investing myself in the
videos right I needed more time like the
the keemstar
and the some ordinary gamer I spent a
lot of time on those videos because it
was a topic I was passionate about and I
was like you know what [ __ ] I got I want
to talk about this stuff so there you go
well being half as entertaining I mean
in your opinion seriously the podcast
where there's no guests are terrible
okay so we are gonna skip chapter 7 & 8
because it's a long video and I don't I
feel like I don't need to address these
points because chapter 7 is about that
I'm not funny and that's totally fine I
mean I'm not gonna fight him and try to
argue that I'm funny I mean he's
entitled to think I'm not funny the
chapter 8 is about that we sometimes
miss report things and get information
wrong and that I totally own you know
sometimes I put my foot in my mouth and
I say the wrong stuff so you know you
can wash that part I I just I don't need
to respond to it because I I own it
you're right I get stuff wrong all the
time on this podcast so that's fine okay
so chapter 9 - poor player that struts
and frets his hour upon the stage
and then is heard no more
[Music]
death okay all right now I'm gonna
discuss one last issue that I have with
you if I hadn't seen this I would not
have made this video in the 27th podcast
you made you had an entire segment where
you talked about shoenice and I was
thinking about having him on the podcast
because he's just such a wild Christ
such a lunatic getting to come here he
eat some deodorant or something he was
like I'll be in LA in a couple weeks or
next month or it was very open-ended I
was like okay well I'll let you know
that we discussed maybe doing a collab
or podcast I don't remember something it
was just an email and then we just
didn't we just never followed up and you
featured a video of him ranting about
you and filthy Frank and he said some
derogatory comments about you and Gila
and it was basically just him making
himself look like an [ __ ] with
insulting you specifically America at
the end so for those of you don't know
shoenice is a crippling alcoholic he got
really that's so I feel like that's
really rude
he's a crippling that's what I'm saying
like I never said anything that mean
about him mmm-hmm you're a crippling
alcoholic sure we I have a lot of
history with you knows we are totally
cool with show in 2011-2012 for some
videos of him basically slamming leaders
of alcohol within a few seconds that's
not all he's famous for how dare you how
dare you diminished shoenice did
shoenice is famous for eating deodorant
too early paint for the paper he's
basically the Billy Goat of YouTube he
got famous for eating and doing crazy
[ __ ] like consuming crazy [ __ ] it's not
just about the alcohol shoo-shoo nice
baby the legend me and my elementary
school friends used to watch too nice
all the time and watching his videos it
does not take a genius to know that this
guy is not in a good place he is he's
he's a raging alcoholic and dude why do
you keep insulting Shu he's a raging
alcoholic I mean goes through phases is
not yeah but a little more complicated
than that
he's almost writing him off as like
shoenice he's an alcoholic you can't
again he's like sjw infor shoe knows you
can't say anything about shoe nice he's
a alcoholic she nice is my dog I don't
know what you're talking about
if you've ever seen his vice documentary
which I recommend you can see that the
guy is not all there he has some issues
okay and deep down it seems like his
intentions are good in general I agree
but there's a lot of issues to be
unraveled when was the last time I seen
my son a little spoiled rotten brat when
you see him again
tell him to tell his mom dirty [ __ ] I'm
getting half you know he's a vet he's a
very interesting guy a very interesting
case study and yeah he's aware of all
that and he must think he's interesting
too because he used him as a punching
bag in front of his audience of over a
million and I'm pretty sure he's drunk
all the time he gets drunk he's done
this about 20 times makes this
anti-semitic ramble and then he erases
it when he Sobers up these are pretty
entertaining and so I'm kind of into
like shoenice hate videos now and he was
aware of that when he gave shoenice
false hope of being on the podcast my
biggest concern was I don't want him in
this office not only because I'm afraid
he's gonna try to kill somebody but I
also don't trust him with the address I
think he would like posted on Twitter
immediately just out of a drunk
vengeance I think he would be an
interesting podcast guest but I would
want like legit security I would want
him patted down before he entered ya
handcuffs look I love shoenice but he's
pretty why he's pretty wild I mean I was
playing it up though for sure mm-hmm
yeah I mean I was goofing out sure nice
for sure but I don't know why he's put
placed in this this like position of
guarding he's like Guardian yeah he's so
fragile all the poor shoenice being
shoenice have been going back and forth
for years like there's so much history
between me and show and he was I mean he
was the reason we were doing this by the
way with dunking on him is because he
was here I have these he was calling you
like an Israeli [ __ ] and [ __ ] like here
let me see I've got all these great shoe
nice tags
here he said he just started tweeting
out all this crazy [ __ ] he goes don't
give single [ __ ] about his subscribers
Jewish people are greedy and only care
for themselves and ela is a [ __ ] I said
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
he's a [ __ ] up [ __ ] you were my huh
you were my help now shoo nice trolls
you until I die like he's a character
you know anyway here's another one he
said [ __ ] off ela is a [ __ ] from Israel
and ela famously said slams more toilet
paper to clean the [ __ ] coming out of
your mouth I mean it's been a back and
forth with Shue but it is all love I
know it does I know it doesn't seem that
way at times but it really is all love
well after restrainin it'll be like a
scene out of Silence of the Lambs where
he's just sitting in a chair will have
to muzzle and put a mask on him because
Ethan does not care about people's
feelings on an individual level that's
on a grand scale
what are you based that's just come on
it's not right
he cares what people think but on an
individual level he does not unless of
course you have something to offer him
now again okay you're just you're I know
weird thing that you know all that I
don't know she only brought him up in
this one segment right that's you know
you bring up shoenice once he doesn't
really know how he'll react it's not
like it's not a big deal honestly I
would have definitely overlooked it
because you know shoenice probably
enjoyed the attention but now here we
are it's been a year since that podcast
and Ethan's had a year to develop as a
podcast
what maker as a host and well he decided
to add shoenice again okay so this clip
again it's totally bad faith criticism
and I'll tell you why I'll play the
video and I'll show you
shoenice is a [ __ ] lunatic in other
news so apparently shoenice has like 20
different accounts and he switches
between them you nice loves ela and
wishes she would forgive him if you guys
don't know he had called you a
Jewish [ __ ] or something sort things
sweet like that shoenice believe it back
that he took that screenshot should tell
you and all you need to know about sure
nice you know what I mean like that's
the image he took from his channel
shoenice deleted videos to see shoenice
would be legendary videos wish upon a
star bro do you guys understand he
literally has 50 old account and he
commented and uploaded all of them it
was it was literally the craziest thing
I've ever seen mm-hmm like oh my god why
are you being such a like he's being
such a he's been such a social justice
where he's so offend about this educated
so fundamental sadness crazy give this a
thumbs up everyone shoenice exposed I
won't come to Cali bro let me know this
are you [ __ ] blowing are you mind
blown yet brought him up for a whole
about six minutes yes talked about how
he has 50 different YouTube accounts and
yeah he basically likes his own comment
and yeah that's on his comments and like
makes it so stop acting like a insane
person I emailed him that spent five
hours replying 100 times I can't get
ahold of them I have no way of getting
all of them even that one I don't really
care because you know it's kind of an
interesting tidbit a weird thing that
unites did oh oh it's an interesting bit
because it's from 50 different shoenice
channels that's more than an interesting
tidbit that's incredible it's the next
one that really kind of gets me today
we've got a special okay you guys hey
love it together of know your meme
featuring the one and only shoe ice you
guys have been a lot of lime here let's
get started okay so on the next podcast
he has a 20 minute segment about get
this him quizzing one of his viewers
about how [ __ ] up shops is a way for a
mental illness on [ __ ] full blast
not really as mental illness that's
really put in words and you're pretty
that's not really what this is though
you're Joe how are you doing today
fantastic even better now I'm talking my
favorite couple on YouTube oh thank you
Joe you're too kind too kind do you know
she's you nice so you're ready to win a
samsung galaxy as my boss and you can
say it's all in good fun
you know there's no negative intention
but I know in my head I know that Ethan
gets some sick pleasure from putting him
on blast so this is one of my favorite
moments he goes you might say it's all
good fun but I know in my head that it's
not so okay dude well you don't really
know nope don't really know and again
this that's the problem with this whole
video is that it's all speculation it's
all speculation that's like shrouded in
the most cynical possible interpretation
that almost doesn't even skirt against
the possibility of reality like that so
you say he chained himself and he [ __ ]
himself in a diaper and fasted for four
or five days did he achieve success in
his hunger strike no he was actually
forcibly removed it but we did not have
that story definitely lines up with the
shoenice we all know and love
no problem stretching my imagination to
believe that but like any spoiled child
he does not know when to quit it's a
segment dude spoiled child that just
shows what a decent kind of way the best
parts coming you are now I remind you
the objective is to get into the shoe
itself ela said to him slam some more
toilet paper
to clean the [ __ ] that's becoming out of
your mouth what provoked this from you
it's really hard and I'm so sorry
horrible well Joe you are entering the
mine of shoe and I like to see that
you've what you've dropped all rationale
all reason imagine that much free time
so this is what we're dealing with
so let me win from how many times as
shoenice ashes you okay so check is
alcohol poisoning so let's just enter
Ethan's mind right now okay shoenice
over a year ago made a 60-second video
where he basically bashes you so let me
let me show you guys what really
happened on that segment and this proves
to you beyond the shadow of doubt that
this is a bad faith criticism now you
know he watched this clip clearly but
what he doesn't tell you is that
shoenice was a willing participant in
this segment and he provided the answer
to all the questions and when the person
gave their answer i will go what is the
answer shoenice tell us and listen to
this let's see but he had talked about
an email and I was heading out to
California and he things like it would
be great for us to get together and I
emailed Ethan a few more times and it
came up you know he would reply to me
and I was just like well can you let me
know within the day and then I I was
just on Twitter and I'm a ballbuster so
I just you know I said hey look you know
you're a Jewish [ __ ] from Israel Thanks
what I said if she was from Tennessee
due to been a [ __ ] from Tennessee I
don't even remember typing it to be
honest you are correct in this point by
the way that whole thing is what anyway
it's part of our beautiful history was
sure nice but it was just a segment and
wait another one EULA how many how many
time do that alcohol poisoning its shoe
nicest question really not goes to
counts they all have visitor and they're
all real I use them exactly how I got to
the point is right yeah that he makes it
look like we're just [ __ ] on
shoenice
but he neglects to mention that shoenice
is participating it's a collaborative
effort yeah it was actually a really fun
thing to do together and we did it Wade
out of people to if you kind of set it
up as if you had led him on
while the you know failing to include
this part that he was led on we did a
segment with him just like you said that
you would and so they did do I think
Dundas know your meme with a lot of
people right where they give us answers
and then we quiz someone and then we
play their answers so it is a
collaborative effort and again it's just
a total bad faith argument to neglect to
say that the truth is that if he showed
that he wouldn't probably just cut this
whole section out because there's really
nothing to criticize us for sure nice in
my opinion I mean really when your wife
to his audience of let's say max 3000
people because well shoenice is channel
the one that he got popular on got taken
down by YouTube I wonder why a big
surprise so now after having all that
progress reset he's basically at square
one
and so he's barely [ __ ] he has no
audience really he has some sick people
who enjoy watching a man fall into
[ __ ] misery and Ethan being one of
those people decides to take this clip
and [ __ ] put it on blast to over a
million people anyway I'm gonna skip
this part making know that you erases it
on one channel reuploads it on another
and it's just I don't he's just on
another level
so because shoenice made a video bashing
your wife you feel that you have a moral
authority to put them on blast in front
of millions bro how deeply is he reading
into this we talk about us all the time
is really got nothing to do with moral
authority or anything on a podcast where
you're making 20k all you nice is making
nothing and just when you think it
couldn't go any deeper you find out that
Ethan is actually entertaining the idea
of taking the bullying further you know
what the sensitive you are he's said
he's so sensitive for sure nice what
happened dan the TV shut off
oh it's back he's so sensitive for poor
shoenice a coward storm wack pack that
one
build of our own shoenice is like anyway
you know what I've seen enough I get it
let's have the man himself shoenice call
in to discuss there yeah you can't go
horizontal if you want to if you want to
turn it the other way I mean as long as
you guys that's fine yeah I guess it's
fine yeah Shu got everything balanced
Shu tell me first of all thank you for
calling in just a broadly what did you
think about go canarios video that guy
is a complete idiot that is the camera
yeah listen he could have done that
whole video Ethan he didn't have to blow
your head off and then throw an
imitation on my son at the end it almost
looked like my kid killed you hmm right
so I mean I know I mean I was just like
dude can you edit it but it already blew
up I'm gonna sneeze wait so you at you
talked with him yeah oh yeah right in
the beginning it came out in everybody
like mediocre and it just is like dude
I'm not gonna watch this no no you gotta
watch it dude your son's in it I'm like
what oh maybe my son and this dude did
something and then I go through go
through go through and I see you sitting
there and this dude comes up and just
like and he just like hacked your
YouTube or something the death of h3h3
you're not going anywhere and I'm just
like dude sorry and then the other it'll
never stop it's just like this this cold
thing of keeping up that video and you
so but that's it I didn't know that you
asked him to edit out the end
why did you ask him to do that you there
yeah oh I was saying oh my gosh I got
you sorry um you said I was saying I
didn't know the humor bro trust knows
over 30 days that congratulations that's
awesome last time I talked to you guys I
was in a blackout well that makes sense
considering the context of the what
happened well I I wanted him to take it
out not only for why are you just gonna
execute somebody for video and views and
I just haven't talked to my son and so
long lost the kid on opiates and he's
gonna throw in his buddy I mean he
doesn't even have the looks to be a
schooi I'm just like hangs it up dude
you were yeah you know they're so edits
on that video now and what did you what
did he say when you asked him to remove
it dude I spent hours on this this is I
said dude I know but you shouldn't even
have put me in the end of the whole day
just the way it all came together right
his whole the whole point like I'm sorry
I was saying the whole ending part was
saying that that we were mean and rude
to you but but I feel like we're bros I
feel like that point didn't really make
sense yeah it's the shape of the
youtubes I bust balls on you guys booty
pie everybody for years they don't get
mad the trees it's the fans that feed
the flame and I've known you guys
forever
and I'm just like oh email email email
message message dude h3 h3 is just I
said I'm using h3 h3 alright I'm the one
that made up 60 accounts that went in
and I've got all the comments and they
finally just said listen you gotta have
this guy in the show I made he
criticized me for making fun of the fact
that you left like a hundred comments
from a hundred different accounts that
is ridiculous how is he gonna figure
this out in here and blame you is what
I'm working right I know you're gonna
watch this Broken Arrow
I just don't know your name or an area
there's hundreds and hundreds of people
from mediocre to I mean everybody tries
to figure this out and maybe it's just a
big act
I don't know they shouldn't have shot
you eat and that's all I'm saying well I
well thank you take sip stir in this
live stream you can absolutely take sips
100% now shoo there was a boy was that
coffee yeah shoot ditch I had a quick
drink in my liver was gonna shut down
and I find I stopped enough so the liver
turns back around there's a certain
point and you get to the top and if you
don't change it it's too late well I'm
glad you're changing it yeah I'm gonna
be a UFC fighter by time yeah you know
what's funny I remember when that go
Canara video came out you were sober and
you were like super healthy and he kept
referring to as an alcoholic like you
were some helpless alcoholic that I
shouldn't make alcoholism was made up
for the weak-minded I'm a raging drunk
I've dropped idiots in one day I've
dropped I buyed ever did heroine I know
I could quit that in the day alcohol
it's just mind over matter I don't have
a mind so we don't and I'm just like hey
meeting a bunch of strangers to tell you
who you got a coach drinking buddy I was
a sponsor for like two weeks dude kept
calling me in the middle of the night I
need a drink bro I'm like well hurry up
the bar is gonna close in an hour I'll
buy you one
and like the 12 steps I'm sorry that's a
bounty monster yeah half of an a a
meeting is literally the judge told Jen
smarten up your act yeah you get a DUI
you got to show the judge up I'm going
to hangar management I don't hit my girl
anymore
That's not me I'm just saying before
DWIs just you what did you think about
him just writing you off as an alcoholic
though and he kept referring to he's an
alcoholic he's an alcoholic I don't know
maybe he had that problem in his family
huh
he's doing crystal meth off his a a book
I have no idea
and then another pretty obsessed about
the video and I'm just like leave me
alone another interesting revelation is
that you
exclaim because there's a whole
conspiracy that I removed his videos but
I saw a tweet of you or an email and a
tweet that says that you reported it and
you know I reported it every time I got
my own personal moderator I got so much
hate that they literally put one lady to
me we're gonna just we're gonna watch
and they they literally my number one
hater he's out of prison for child porn
my other hater got Doc's by a dude he's
been just I mean the shoenice hate is
slowly but surely imploding I knew it
would but spike always wins over evil
right yeah that's right but so so are
you saying that we got everybody else's
name for a second it was you who report
this is like right here I'm sitting at
the table with you guys oh yeah I'm
blind I just notice your heads are way
in the back I'm on the side so it's a
weird way there it's gonna look better
on the shiny thing go ahead bruh shoot
you were trying to learn how to listen
and not ramble on that's okay it's
alright you know the marijuana use has
tripled since I quit alcohol oh you know
it's over you smoke weed chill bro yeah
that was at the a meeting last night
shoot
so it was you you reported his videos to
YouTube and got them removed oh yeah
without a doubt
you know each other just came in a
speech so Broken Arrow I reported your
video on the main channel the second
time when your idiot buddy did it and
I'll keep doing it for the rest of my
with somebody oh yeah so what did you
tell your youtube don't forget to
subscribe to shoenice on Zack's that i
could through that and subscribe what
channel are we subscribing to now 5010
it's always been its xu9 22 forever now
that was my big mistake I think we
talked about that changing the name all
the time shoot I'm 22 and I can
miel you're killing it on cammy all
right you a nice 22 that's how I make a
living now you guys started it out that
Steve will do it told me about it and
you guys bought a bunch of them and
everybody that watches your vids it's
just an archives well it's his cameo oh
my god and then they come in they get on
birthdays a knock coronavirus people are
just all depressed why don't I come in
thank God sure they're happy for five
minutes
so hich had to raise my price not the 20
though Hey I would sell myself for a
Jimmy John's sub bro
so shoenice only doll at rate flat rate
you get the whole batteries are charging
yeah I don't know yeah sorry guys 22 on
cameo shoot nice 22 on YouTube so um
we'll get them we'll get them links in
there after that's all so lovely do you
guys later and no idea what do you tell
your YouTube rep when you report his
videos um this is usually just reporting
and flagging just to get somebody's it
shut down never done it in my life I
hate actors I hate people that send the
pizza to your house the people that SWAT
somebody but now this was more personal
and I tried to tell this dude you know
and I mean he looks like some kind of a
bird on a fence all on that you know
leave me alone you are I will always say
do you have I got grown men on puppets
for years I don't know what it is all
I'm doing is eating toilet paper I
looked it up I you I I googled it it's
called um celebrity worship syndrome
CWS look it huh there's this dude's I
can't get over me no matter what I do in
life I slam a keg of beer every day I go
out and feed the homeless I fix my life
I got a good job with cameo
it's never good not for the pencil dick
Papa club mm-hmm well it's good enough
for me I'm proud of you that you're
sober and you're making a living on
cameo mmm
and I and I hope that all of our fans
will purchase it
Kamio for $20 flat why don't you have me
and keemstar fight dude you be my
sponsors i'll nobody there us speaking
of here looks like the backside of a
rooster I wanted to ask you about
because keep star accused you of being a
rapist didn't he yes but the sad thing
is about King stars his anger and it
probably way before YouTube has always
got the better of them you know what I
mean most stuff you just act angry dude
you ever annoyed but I love the way you
do it bro absolutely beautiful
no what is it do you have anything to
say to keemstar I just wanted to say
that back in the day I was famous it was
me jenna gargles and the people this
hanging out watching Shane Dawson you
were around a little bit and then RWJ
view got in that show that was the holy
booth it rose you to the top and the
next day I wake up I got 50,000
subscribers they're like oh so I got
like whiteboy seven bogie two nine eight
eight when he was still fat mm-hmm
we're just like hanging out and
everybody's furious Pete la vie smacks
mofo he talks about me all the time
because I made his channel people will
realize how the basic is filthy Frank
max multiple and idubbbz
there's only one set of hands throwing
their legs but yeah man he just gave me
a huge shout out yesterday for cameo he
bought a bunch of cameos and he cooked
me on his channel
some people have respect for helping you
but some people don't like I helped out
qui fili fee um
la breasts think who else did I help out
[Laughter]
the drama skirt right I thought keemstar
was different than drama alert I always
heard drama word h3h3 Jake Paul sleeping
with his brother Logan
No I come in and on my Twitter I was big
I mean you guys remember and I called
you a name and keemstar first thing out
of his Shogun tada shoe no he's called
you and Ethan bye mama so I come in yeah
whatever so he never really liked me so
then I did a parody of them and let's
get right into the shoes everything and
he just got mad and mad and mad and I
hit one tweet here it is right here
excuse me guys I lost my Marge Simpson
boys quit drinking I'll try it yeah do
the dishes Marge Kinney that's so oh I
was just gonna go to sleep but I just
found out shoenice rapes kids FML and
there's like three four thousand people
you know what I mean
you can DOX me you can you know take my
mom's ashes and throw them into a pool I
don't say I read kids so I go into his
messages DMS I'm like game star I'll
show you the proof
these guys are he sends me back this
video I sent you nice people a lot
bigger than you and mess with me though
don't so I sent him the proof he just
blacks me disappears for years and then
the guy he got the info off of my Google
hangout haters the leader gets arrested
for child porn distribution now I'm just
thinking oh my god this guy's a metal
guitar player was he a real pedophile or
was he trying to docks me or one of my
you know buddies that went after him I'm
hoping it's the second you know and I
mean I'm hoping he's stuck on a sex
offenders list for the rest of his life
we're taking that kind of deviled [ __ ]
and putting it on me if he was a Fed
I'll use a pedal either way so keemstar
years later he's got a poster he's
fighting with h3h3 and because you did a
podcast with me he's like oh I didn't
even watch it
and he's just like dude so I emailed
them you didn't return it he threw up
that video on broken arrow I said I
can't believe this guy with this many
subs and this so much money he's making
would put up a video that was already
taken down by twice by YouTube and you
know it might be not even event the
reports from people it might have just
been because YouTube picks up a video
it's like when you get that train wreck
that's why I don't watch a live leak it
was good money when they stopped the
money I was out of there that
desensitized the soul watching lively
called a problem yeah
so I went a call real quick like I said
two sentences so - yeah man this dude is
a complete idiot he wants to fight back
and forth with you that's fine I don't
have any problem with this dude
just don't say I read kids bro alright I
know you're watching Keaney and I got
you that strike and you're gonna not
upload for a week lessons learned
problem did he ever apologize for
accusing you being raised an [ __ ] he
just belong to you he blocked you yeah
yeah he's now yeah he blocked me on
Twitter cuz I mean this family sick of
it these are real people's names that
these people that hate me there's a real
dark a true nice world I don't know
where they have you having some kind of
evil their leader was a child corn
distributor and I still wanted to hang
out with this guy who I wish she would
just make a video and tell us tell you
about him a [ __ ] pedophile he's in
prison hate him a letter
so did I I thought it was kind of rich
how keemstar uploads a video go canarios
like he was mean to shoenice but keeps
our called you a [ __ ] rapist i think
that's a little meaner listen the whole
thing was like I emailed him this whole
thing and I said I'm going to sue you
dude that's libel and slander you told
two or three million I know people I got
five thousand for ten times less of an
audience and he just I think he was
trying to clean up his act like throwing
that up oh look at what a you don't
remember this sure I remember every
very easy keemstar you a Broken Arrow go
start something frickin you know country
band we all just a bunch of pencil dicks
chill I love ya I'll be at my time's up
but see I'm doing better
I don't 40 emails anymore just Florida
time no you've been great no you can
talk you can spam Zack oh you want I'll
get a better microphone that's not
swinging in the wind
[Laughter]
whew twenty-two shoenice 22 on cameo and
youtube games I just wanted food done
thing out on the record forever yeah
Ethan a needle and me have been getting
along forever I knew these guys before
big nation and Gandhi and arrow
keemstar you're a lesbian book club yeah
thank you she all right bro you take
care buddy all right
oh yeah subscribe subscribe subscribe so
this is actually correct crazy
revelation that shoenice was offended
that go kanaru
used his son to murder Broken Arrow
Broken Arrow and and soon and then soon
I stole asked him to remove that part
from the video I would have never
expected that that's a twist and then Co
kanaru told him to [ __ ] off so who's
being the bully to Portia what he that
is such a twist
I can't just outed him I mean it was
interesting to hear about it from
shoenice perspective I did find that
whole same pretty weird which we're
gonna watch I guess we haven't watched
yet yes I see she has like shoenice his
son like chasing you he saw in the end
shoenice joins him to kill me for
revenge
his son yeah and by the way sure nice is
estranged from his son and I think I
think and actually he knows that because
he showed a clip right and I saying that
and then
to use his son like that in a way mean
sure homies so he implying that she
wants to kill me and she wasn't cool
with it and he asked him to take it down
Goku Naru said no Broken Arrow Broken
Arrow and also shoot confirming that he
was the one that got it taken down yeah
he said both times he wrote his YouTube
rap that was that shoenice cliff twit oh
my god it's weird cuz he like he put so
much faith into shoenice I've like a
weird hair here ela you're gonna have to
forgive me okay look how big it is what
you saw that okay we're cutting that no
you leave that he puts so much faith in
the shoenice story he even says I
wouldn't have even made this video yeah
a few times if you think isn't only poor
shoenice and then she and then for sure
nice - come on that's crazy and also I
really love shoenice the whole thing
about keemstar keep stirring and then oh
by the way good so go kanaru gave this
video to keemstar to re-upload right
right and a parent and keemstar is
always promoting this video and you know
and they seem to be cool with each other
so how is it that me bowling poor
shoenice prompted this whole video yet
keemstar who said he's a child rapist
publicly based on no that's a pass based
on nothing based on nothing he and then
you and I said keemstar blocked him when
he confronted him about it yeah didn't
apologize
so let me get this straight I'm the
[ __ ] next to the dude who called him
a child rapist Wow
and how many people is that that keeps
track used to being child rapists no
I've lost track but I do you gotta
appreciate there's so much irony the
shoenice is almost the key to all this
shoenice has locked the meaning to this
whole thing really epic considering that
he was also the main reason for making
this video a big reason and he was the
one that deleted and he was the one that
was most offended by full circle so
lesbo Canara likes to say we've come
full circle yeah
let me quote let me just wrap this up
here before we watch the outro sketch
shoenice was offended that he include
his child killing me he asked him to
remove it go Canara told him no kokoro
is cool with keemstar who accused
shoenice of being a child rapist
publicly he gets a pass but I'm the
biggest [ __ ] in the world for
Beurling poor shoenice shoenice admits
to taking down both of his videos
reporting it to his youtube rep and and
getting them removed for harassing
shoenice so also kiemce has been
promoting this video for years but in
that very first segment about Jairo
cynical Brian is the one that debunked
it so he knows he knows wrong house
caves start promoting this video has the
ultimate he goes this is the ultimate
video when huge so Kim stars apparently
watch this video the first point came to
our nose is wrong in fact he's the one
that made the video saying it was
totally wrong and then keeps hers the
one that accuse shoenice of being a
child rapist the whole impetus for this
video being made in the first place
something does it make sense you know
what I think you wanna know what I think
I think Kim star hasn't watched this
video I think you watched the first five
minutes that's funny I think he's like
shoo nice isn't it oh [ __ ] I should know
upload it I shouldn't share that I think
most people haven't watched this video
Thank You keemstar
say it again say it again q-star listen
let's watch the outro sketch here now
this is the reason this video kept keeps
getting removed yeah and speaking I mean
we're
watch it but cut it before he actually
shoots the part where he executes Smee
because the surrounding stuff is pretty
vulgar - okay but look this is only by
the way six minutes of an hour and
thirty five minute video if he cared
that much he I mean YouTube literally
said you are doing an execution and at
the end of the video if you cared you
would have just cut this part out and
I'm really at it but for some reason I
don't know why he never did that and I
mean obviously no one would have a
problem with that at that point he's
really proud of this part I mean I think
he said well let's watch it let's see
everyone shoenice again either way for
the fourth time Ethan my body from h3h3
has given me a shout-out he's called me
the moral center of YouTube a legend
Ethan and he loved from h3 podcast by
the way she own ice has crazy rapport
with other people too like Maximo faux
and shoe and ice are always doing all
this crazy beef he's dressing up as
Marge and doing all this crazy fit for
max like I'm not the only one that
interacts with shoenice on this level
you know I'll have to be interviewed by
you guys I know we had some arguments
back in the day that was totally my
fault just drunk in jest trolling with
just my door for you a public apology
yeah I think that's the back issues head
I kind of remember when he uploaded the
stuff oh that's shoe yeah yeah yeah my
gonna be a green-screen himself he's got
good like I'll make the back because
it's just mean he doesn't deserve to be
made fun of and I mean if you look at
leafy's channel all he does is make fun
of kids and like vulnerable people nice
is not a vulnerable person come on
that's so stupid
making fun of these people they're just
it's just sad sending like millions of
like K
to just harass these people and honestly
it is kind of just turned into bowling I
know we make fun of people this argument
that I'm blowing shoenice is just so
lame
I mean come on who are the best be sure
that it's somebody who deserves it we'd
never find someone with ten views and be
like hey they [ __ ] this kid for trying
to follow his passions and live this is
that ticking his video yeah
here's making fun of a Joe is very
dramatic obviously has an eating
disorder like what the [ __ ] man can you
just find like someone to pick on your
I'll admit that that Joey World Tour
thing was a stretch hmm that was a bad
point that I made back then like I mean
seriously did at this point it's
literally just bowling the guy needs
house support not [ __ ] ridicule by a
thousand raging kids on the Internet
stop we were a little more delicate than
that and I just would like to see that
same delicacy across the board because
this is not this is not the community
that I mean I think most of us want to
be a part of so I just want to say for
the record that we are hypocrites
it all comes full circle eventually
mm-hmm and Ethan Klein your time is up
[Music]
so this is building off the intro sketch
where their sketches thought where he
bought a gun in the beginning he was
like a weird dude with obsessed with me
and wants to kill me so I think it's
just picking up from where those
sketches left off is he in a dorm room
or maybe it's a doorman I think is this
bedroom
oh so this is sure nice his son which is
a little I mean that is a little
insensitive why should I sit anywhere
man yeah it's but as you and I said in
your video that he's estranged from his
son yeah let the hunt begin
so they hunt me down and murder me
essentially this is me obviously fat I
don't have to walk here I mean come on
people people have referenced this as
light hearted you tell me if this is
like murder it was just a light-hearted
haunting and execution scene
[Music]
very dramatic
[Music]
they found my DNA they're hunting me the
kid does kind of look like soon Isis son
I will say he casted the part while
there I'm running all in
they got me they found me sure nice and
Sun found me oh so this is the part
where we should just cut away but it's
very I mean it's very graphic here you
can just edit out and post right then
well we're just off of it yeah but like
show here show this frame so like he
just shoots me in the face at
point-blank I mean so it is pretty
graphic and creepy it's very menacing
manly I can say from my personal point
of view I did not like seeing it it
didn't feel right there's a clip of him
saying he thought it went too far in
retrospect - but I will say like
obviously I don't feel like he's gonna
kill me but it was it's a little - I
think it is too far like I would never
do that
like it's not funny and it's not it's
really serious and ominous and creepy
and here I'll show it like he kills me
and then they like comments spit on my
body and shut it's like so it and it's
just very
I told first of all I had nothing to do
with this video getting removed
apparently it was all shoenice I totally
understand why YouTube wouldn't want
this being acceptable on the block he
knows that - like you said if you really
wanted it up you just cut this out right
obviously so they start spitting on me
it's just not that serious
I don't know ish so there you have it
the death of h3h3
i gouken ro2 masterpiece garbage no no
you know i yeah he ends on one final
note I'd like to share something my
father once told me I just gunned the
[ __ ] kicked out of me for bullying my
brother and he said to me did you just
say his dad was beating the [ __ ] out of
him so that's how I seemed to be he what
he stated if you're gonna dish it out
you'd better be ready to take it whoa
did he I mean he showed one example of
maybe not being able to take criticism
in the case of like the hypocrisy and in
the n-word controversy and I fully
accept that but I feel like I get a lot
of [ __ ] here on YouTube yeah so I'm
sorry your dad is [ __ ] I feel like
I'm sorry that your dad beat you you
shouldn't have done that
here he says by the way that even he and
mostly I was not made to be a friendly
video I've said that it's supposed to be
abrasive same with the ending skit I
even felt some regret about the ending
skit afterward but not on a guidelines
level okay it was mainly on like a
personal empathetic level I was like
okay there's definitely a bit edgy but I
had very specific reasons for so he
admit like it sounds like he kind of
knew he went too far I appreciate him
saying that I I feel like yeah I mean it
was a little disturbing
for sure so that's it I mean wow we did
it long one I don't even know how long
you know what you want to say though
about gochenour Oh again I think he
actually think he's a talented guy and
he and he put this whole thing together
and I think he did a really good job I
just think he was probably more careless
than he would have been if he knew that
a millions of people were gonna see it
right and I could say the same thing for
myself when I was making videos for what
I knew was a very small audience you had
less care about like some details right
but but you know what I it's fine you
know I I think he did I think he did a
good video obviously there was a demand
for it at the time everyone saying
content cop Ethan and so he did that he
filled that need and and then you know
keep people that came star boosted it
which is ironic but anyway no hate to
this to go canard oh you know he's got a
little cult following now and he's he's
doing this thing so you know best of
luck to him god bless but obviously at a
certain point I I have to acknowledge
this video and and talk about it so
that's what we did here today so with
that that was a huge undertaking but we
did it so I hope you guys enjoyed that I
hope that cleared up some things and you
know if you guys like to let me know
I'll watch h3 hate videos all day if you
guys like it I'll make I'll make a
career out of watching h3 you hate
videos if you guys like it
but anyway have a great weekend what do
we got next week William Osmond right
cool and then after that Oliver tree
yeah baby problems coming out we're
planning some fun things I'll retrieve
best-guess greatest gift also under
million subs I believe when he came on I
just remembered
but thank you for watching guys I hope
that was watchable I don't know if it
was or not I think no more or less than
our typical let me know what you thought
apparently there's another new h3 video
that everyone's talking about called
everybody hates ether so maybe I'll
watch that next time maybe in two years
submit your favorite h3 hate videos to
podcast at HDS reproduction I'm serious
submit them if you guys like this all
watched another one like once a month
give us a please alright guys thank you
all for watching have a great weekend we
love free Shh and we'll see you on the
flip side of the flip side all right
[Music]
[Music]